uh I don't have my gavel oh
we will now open the public hearing on
House Bill 297 and recognize
representative Almy
there thank you madam chair and
committee on I have a testimony which is
a little long so I'm not going to talk
most of it but I did want the many
people on this committee who are new
enough that you haven't been told what
dedicated funds are and why they belong
in this committee
on what
on
what has been going on for the last 20
four years I think it is
on
as we've corralled the dedicated funds
of the state
on
but this bill is every single term
every single year the dedicated funds
committee gets together
and after
the chair talks with
the person at Das who is handling the
reporting of dedicated funds there
and uh he we have a five-year cycle
through which every dedicated Fund in
the state goes on organized into
agencies of the state
and
it took us a couple of of terms to
figure out what we were doing and get it
right and we started to get it right
three years ago
and now where that is completely right I
hope I think uh now now we're turning
out a spreadsheet along with the bill
every
every year that shows
what we did or didn't do with each of
the dedicated funds that was on our list
for that year
and I handed you
just a part
of the spreadsheet for this time you can
find it under the dedicated funds
committee under statutory committees
um in
uh
for you and look at it for yourself it's
more in the form of a draft than
than a final version because there can
frequently
observations or questions in the
comments section
that
may be worthy of following up five years
later
on but there are also explanations in
the purpose and the funding source
that explain
very succinctly what that dedicated fund
is there for
and where it's getting its money from
some of the comments tend to be on
this fund has been increasing the amount
of money in the fund for quite some time
and
they said that they're going to be
building a capital project soon or we
didn't get any information from them
about that but we didn't have time and
so it's still a question
um
so
it's
that's
the spreadsheet that goes along with the
annual report the annual report went in
from representative major
last fall
and is under the statutory committee's
dedicated funds you just look up
dedicated and it comes up
but the dedicated funds of the state
are formed for a specific purpose
they were planned to be funded either by
donations and grants or a specific fee
fine or penalty that is relevant to
their purpose
but after early challenges the courts
allowed that relevance to be very broad
as long as the legislature has created
the law
they defer to the legislature usually
when the link is tenuous
most active dedicated funds do have a
strong relevancy to the program that
they're supporting
and
legislators put these in in an attempt
to get funding or more funding for a
wide range of causes that they fear the
current legislature or a future one will
choose not to support having other
priorities
too many are put in saying they will get
funding from donors or grants or future
Appropriations which never appear
it takes a lot of work to develop a
donor State stream or grants for
something that perhaps should have been
done by the state
or that people outside think should have
been done by the state
um
this is kind of a warning that when our
committee does get new dedicated fund
requests
if it is not based on a specific fee or
other
or appropriation that's actually
occurring or something like that we need
to look at them with a real BDI because
otherwise
five years later we're probably going to
be repealing it
because nothing happened
so
dedicated funds in the rules fall under
the purview of our committee
but the people who assigned the bills
frequently send them also to finance and
sometimes to other policy committees
so
um sometimes those we get as a second
committee sometimes we never see until
it gets to the dedicated fund committee
the dedicated fund committee includes
senators and house members and is has
been
pretty much chaired by the chair of ways
and means over the years I think once
I chaired it but then I appointed myself
Clerk
and let representative major chair
because the spreadsheet gets done by the
clerk
and it's a lot of extra work
so
the committee is is charged I've said
this part
this bill is the result of the second
year of the second cycle and covers the
Department of Environmental Services the
lottery Liquor Commission the university
system of New Hampshire the courts and
the Department of Justice
in fact it's a fairly
slow moving
um it
the second year is a fairly light load
except for Environmental Services which
I was dreading but they are really good
at presenting themselves
some of the Departments are not
and it's pulling teeth to get them to
figure out what they're doing and then
put it back together again
so
um
in the first cycle we didn't have our
act together yet and this year we asked
why we were treating
The Liquor Commission the Lottery
Commission and the university system as
part of our review they have separate
Audits and their cash flow goes directly
to segregated funds so they appear in
what I call the telephone book which is
about that thick when you have it
printed out and they hand us
the the printout on the committee but
everybody else looks it up online
um
these these three
the two commissions and the university
system appear in that book with zero
dollars and zero dollars occurred and
zero dollars at the end of the year and
practically
um no wording at all about their purpose
and their funding on
and that is because they do these
separate extensive audits
um which are separately reported
and
in the past we had simply removed the
Seabrook decommissioning fund from the
list of funds very early on because it
was obvious that that uh
it's I believe received all of the
monies that it needs
it cannot be touched
for very obvious reasons that if we
drain the Seabrook decommissioning fund
and Seabrook needs to be decommissioned
that's a huge amount of money
so it is off the book from anything that
we can or should do
but our new comptroller asked that
similar funds and the lottery liquor and
University system
ought to be continue to be listed with
an asterisk which states why they are
exempt from reporting as a dedicated
fund and that is sections one to three
of the bill
um we
we removed them from a number of places
and established
if I remember correctly
an asterisk
um
yes on section one the following are
Exempted from the reporting and review
requirements of 612 e and 612j
and
the section four
repeals a fund that was set up to accept
donations to the university system for
scholarships
which were already being provided by the
university system
under its regular student aid these were
specific for the children of
deceased firefighters and police that
were killed in action I believe
and
and the university system was already
doing this
so nobody directed any donations to this
fund on the University system kept doing
it and they said uh
why don't you get it away I mean why
don't you remove it I will say I
expected there to be a Amendment
um this morning
which I guess is going to have to be
passed out later because
there was something left out
on in
the final version of this which I did
not read carefully enough and compare
with the spreadsheet notes on there is a
section in 187 a 20 a
Roman 2.
which is dedicated fund to 78 which says
that uh
this fund is created and is doing the
following work and that needs to be
removed since we're removing it from 612
and since it doesn't do anything
so
um that's going to have to
um I thought that that we had that
coming out it should be coming out of
drafting
fairly soon uh gen Force said she'd take
care of it
so
um but it's that kind of detail work
that
cleaning up our statutes that the
dedicated funds committee does most of
section five repeals of funds set up for
grateful citizens to donate to the Cold
Case homicide attorney who works at
Justice or who should be working at
Justice I think the position's still
vacant but the man retired
in over five years only one 100
contribution has been recorded and the
department was instructed by us to find
a way to spend it on some Cold Case
issue and thank the donor before this
bill comes into effect next January
so that we could
avoid having to send it to the general
fund when the donor was told that this
was going to be for cold cases
um
we spent
15 minutes discussing that but
um so um
and then section 6 is just the effective
date which is the beginning of next year
to
um
I'm not quite sure why it's the
beginning of next year I can't remember
but
but that's it for the bill
and thank you representative would you
go into questions yes uh representative
ulry
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question representative Olney
so just to distill this down
this gets rid of
redundant
uh funds
right or just use funds or unused funds
this only is removing it's not adding or
it's not adding what it does do
sometimes is to get and last last year
we the year before last we had done this
uh to get the Departments to say oh
we've got this money here why do we
still have that money here how can we
best use it and
um two years ago we got
uh
safety I believe it was to on
take the money that they had in two
separate funds on
that had been accumulating gradually
over the years and on was no longer
receiving money
to on spend in a
version of the program that they were
supposed to be doing that will
essentially create a base for the future
without having to spend any more money
thank you
follow up and then representative plate
just uh line 19 uh paragraph five uh
since I was co-sponsor of the original
bill
and I know that this was put in
specifically at the request of numerous
individuals you're not telling me that
one hundred dollars
yeah
yeah that's what happened unless
do you have a question at least one
individual feels strongly enough that
they dedicate a lot of their time to
going out and getting people to provide
contributions they don't do it yeah
thank you manager um representative
Platt has a question
thank you uh I understand this is
essentially a housekeeping Bill to
continue review okay good
um you raise my eyebrows with a Seabrook
fund I thought that was at a federal
level uh so uh there are two funds One
Federal one state on well the state was
responsible as I I mean this was this
was back about 10 years ago when we
discussed this so I'm not quite sure of
my facts but I think that this is the
sole decommissioning fund and it is in
some way on the state's books
and the state on assessed as I recall
on the nuclear plant for years and
probably still is assessing it a little
um
to make sure that there's sufficient
money in there to do the full
decommissioning as has been done for
Vermont Yankee in the last few years
picked up a neck and my life has been in
the utilities industry
thank you other questions yes
Representatives Pillsbury
thank you madam chair
so it
I think this is obvious I just want to
be absolutely sure there are only two
funds that this bill terminates
and that's in article four and five
those two other skills this year that's
the least we've had for quite a while
actually okay so everything in our
sections one two and three is purely for
the purpose of exempting reporting
requirements that's the thrust of the
bill
um when you do your Amendment
on page two
line 17
you could delete relative to where it
appears twice excuse me what was that
because the amendment's already being
done yeah page two line 17 has a
redundant phrase
uh oh relative to relative two yes it
does
um I don't know if we can get that
deleted
I'll try thank you
a question from me if you just just to
be sure this amendment will be
completely germane to the original Bill
oh yes great thank you definitely uh
representative has a question yes thank
you madam chair thank you representative
only just um understanding the liquor
lottery in University system are part of
this Exempted reporting because they're
doing their own audits anyway there's
something about the fish and game in
there
um are they auditing themselves are they
doing audits as well because I see that
that's they're Exempted as well
yeah and and this was done who who was
Exempted got pulled out of the files by
the Comptroller
the fishing game fund uh I would like to
see their audits frankly I've never seen
a fishing game audit and they have a
very complicated series of Which is less
complicated than used to be of of sub
funds that we do get to take a look at
but or we have gotten to take a look at
but they have this General overall fund
that I
do not I was on division one in finance
20 years ago something and
and we did have fish and game in our
purview as I recall we certainly had to
fight about their bills and
I don't remember us spending very much
time on their fund at that point though
later on it turned out that fishing game
The Fish and Game fund was being very if
the management was very difficult
let's put it that way
uh representative ulery if there are no
other questions yeah
let's go around first time first so
representative fellows
thank you I'm just trying to understand
what I'm looking at here in in on that
fish and game issue on line 10.
that's an account that where they put
money received from
fines and and
you know some kind of penalties
so my question is
is the intent to eliminate that account
so that if somebody were to ask the
question you know how much revenue did
you bring in from fines they would not
be able to answer that question
um it does not eliminate the account
what it does is it
says it will say with an asterisk the FI
this is Exempted from the reporting and
review requirements of 612 e and 612j I
would have been uh
and 612 e and J are the dedicated fund
review
where it is reviewed is as the fish and
game fund inside of Finance
and the accounting that has to be done
separately by the Auditors that do the
cat I think the Auditors that do the
kafir on continues and the finance
responsibility continues
but what the only thing that the
dedicated fund committee has seen is the
zero zero zero charts
on because the fund is considered to be
off book by the accounting departments
follow-up uh yes so I I thought I said I
understood until you made that last
comment
so all of these These funds have
balances of zero or they at the end of
the year they have only for the
dedicated funds purposes
they are accounted for separately under
the state accounting system
and they are audited separately during
the uh
the um kafir audit
the the comprehensive Financial annual
Financial
thank you review report whatever it is
any other first time questions
okay seeing none representative ulery
representative Albany you may
you may uh former representative Ober
Rand
because the Liquor Commission didn't
bother to do any accounting
uh in essence uh I don't think it was
that bad was it yeah I I'm trying to
remember it took that subpoena from the
commission to get them to to give us any
information because they said they
weren't a state agency
but that's one of the reasons that the
this was put in there are you now saying
that they are under the reorganization
actually providing uh information
uh in an accounting fashion that can be
seen either by the public or legislators
well I'm saying that they are providing
no information to the dedicated funds
committee commission what I need here is
the Comptroller to explain herself
and I don't know if we'd want to call
her for a work session
it might be good to all right yeah that
might be helpful to do a follow-up on
that okay
thank you madam chair thank you thank
you for your testimony
are there any other pink cards for house
bill 297.
could I just make a comment this is just
the most questions I think we have ever
had
okay we're some of us are still learning
about this so we'll do a little work
session as a full committee to learn a
little bit more
this representative Ames before you
close this uh
I think maybe a word needs to be said
that all the work that representative
almi has done over the years has been
complemented and she's been in
partnership with representative major
who together they've done extraordinary
work in pulling together uh information
that just wasn't attended to in the past
and cleaning up
uh you know a series of accounts that
needed to be cleaned up so that's I
think that should be on the record thank
you well said thank you very much
representative and with that we will
close the public hearing on House Bill
297.
okay we'll Now open up the public
hearing on House Bill 450.
and represent and recognize the prime
sponsor which is representative
Schamberg who is he there he is
if you have noticed Madam chair I've
graduated from two crutches
to one the doctor said I can do away
with my Walker and the two crutches and
move out of kindergarten to Primary
School by using one Correctional
so
and in a three weeks or so he'll put me
on a cane
so
okay
thank you madam chair and house Ways and
Means Committee members for this
opportunity to present house bill
450. I am representative Tom shamberg
Merrimack County six I represent the
towns of Wilmot and Sutton House Bill
450 is an act relative to removing the
net operating loss nol deduction limit
on taxable income under the business
profits tax BPT
for those new to some of the issues that
come before this committee the net
operating loss made its appearance here
last session historically in 2014 a
commission to study business taxes was
formed that included the study of the
carryover and deductions of the net
operating loss to assess its tax policy
in order to maintain a balance between
competitiveness and Revenue
the three criteria used to measure the
competitiveness of each State's
corporate tax base are given equal
weight one the availability of certain
credits deductions and exemptions to the
ability of taxpayers to deduct their net
operating loss and three a host of
smaller tax-based issues the federal
corporate income tax and New Hampshire's
business profits tax is designed to tax
only the profits of a corporation
however a yearly profit snapshot may not
fully capture a corporation's true
profitability for example a corporation
in a highly cyclical industry may look
very profitable during the boom years
but lose substantial
amounts during the bust years when
examined over the entire business cycle
the corporation may actually have an
average profit margin examples of
cyclical Industries those are things you
can live with or without or travel
construction hotels luxury goods
Airlines Etc the non-cyclical industries
things you probably always need are
utilities Health Care Consumer Staples
like toothpaste soap Etc
the deduction for net operating loss
helps ensure that over time the
corporate income tax is a tax on the
average of profitability
this is especially true for New
Hampshire businesses that suffer losses
either from starting up or during tough
Economic Times without the nol deduction
corporations and a cyclical industry
Industries pay much higher taxes than
those in stable Industries even assuming
identical average profits over time
simply put the nol deduction helps to
level the playing field among cyclical
and non-cyclical industries
we here in the new in the house Ways and
Means have tried to provide an Optimum
business tax climate for New Hampshire
in the past few years there have been a
lot of tax legislation all under the
heading to promote our New Hampshire tax
advantage and improve our business
climate and the examples include a
decrease in business tax rates single
sales Factor apportionment market-based
sourcing apportionment and increased
filing thresholds
I have heard members of our legislature
speak ill of the tax laws made in
Washington D.C that affect our residents
and businesses the tax Foundation has
rated the New Hampshire business tax
climate concerning the New Hampshire nol
as some of the worst in the nation as to
corporate taxes
here we are trying to promote the New
Hampshire tax advantage yet in 20
21 through 2022 session the legislature
voted to only allow up to 80 percent of
the federal taxable income as the cap on
nol deductions by conforming to section
172 of the IRC in effect on or after
December 31st 2018.
this change is not a great this change
is not a great climate for small
businesses or startup businesses that
often lose money in the first few years
we are taxing them with the bet
but now are also limiting their nol
deductions which can have devastating
effect in their short and long-term
viability
from 2020 business profits profile the
U.S business administration office of
advocacy the state of New Hampshire had
a hundred and thirty six thousand five
hundred and thirty five businesses or 99
of the small business makeup in New
Hampshire they employed
three hundred thousand six hundred and
twenty eight employees the small
businesses of New Hampshire are crucial
the dra interprets the change to the
eighty percent limitation of the nol as
follows a reduction in net operating
loss deduction taken by the taxpayer
increases tax revenues for the state
I see this as a tax and a tax increase
upon the taxpayer the businesses of New
Hampshire
the solution to this tax increase is
that the house Ways and Means Committee
should not force the New Hampshire
business Community especially the small
businesses and the startups to pay their
BPT before they fully utilize their nol
deduction carry forwards as has been
allowed by the law up until 2022.
this bill for BPT purposes does not
change the carry forward of 10 years
which Most states allow 20 years
and secondly the amount of nol generated
in a tax year that can be carried
forward may not exceed 10 million
this bill only asks at the nol deduction
up to 80 percent of taxable income be
changed
thank you madam chair and
I'm going to let the next expert handle
the technical questions I sure are going
to be coming
from this group and that's Jim ucelo
your cellular I don't have any more pink
cards so if they're out there please
send them my way okay can you send that
out for me uh may I ask you a question
though Madam chair you can always ask
her thank you so much
um we I have requested some legislative
history from our researcher but can you
in a nutshell explain where did this
bill get passed was it is a house bill a
Senate bill when did it happen because
if this never made it to my radar the
change to conform with IRC
Madam chair I have a little story to
tell you okay
first it was voted and approved here to
have the change and I was the only
representative that voted against it
it then moved forward to the house
and it was almost the last bill of the
day
back in May or June I believe and
I had made my presentation the
opposition came up and said it's a 19-1
vote let's vote
and I did make this presentation
during that time period
so
that's when it happened and you were in
the front row I think somewhere
okay thank you so much you're welcome
Madam chair
well good morning my name is Jim uselio
I live in Hollis and as um
representative said I think I'm really
here to help illustrate the issue and
you know give you technical guidance
um
I'm not sure how much history you want
on this issue or just jump into the
example
um
I think I probably should take a few
minutes to go over the history just a
tad so again when we say net operating
loss that's a business's deductions over
their income and so often what happens
is a business will either during a Downy
or recession or maybe in a startup yeah
they often lose money so they may have a
loss in one year and incoming in next
year and so when a business files a tax
return again they pay taxes on their
income and so this net operating loss
deduction under the Internal Revenue
code and I think probably every state
has one is really a means to kind of
take into account that businesses income
goes up some years and down some years
and so the nol is meant to kind of
smooth that over and so
this I'll call it a glitch if you will
um you may know that under the BBT we
use our reference to the Internal
Revenue code changes every few years and
right now we use the 18 code and that's
in figuring out gross business profits
the Nano and the gross business profits
is before the net operating loss
deduction so you start out with gross
business profits you have some
adjustments you will push in your income
and then you basically layer in the net
operating loss deduction and so the net
operating loss deduction had always been
well at least since 1996 it was tied to
the 96 section 172 which basically just
meant when you when you a business
calculates their income in New Hampshire
they follow the 18 code for the gross
business profits but then in this quote
one that's a net operating loss
deduction they follow the 96 code which
again just says basically you can deduct
your nol
um and so excuse me last year
when
um
this reference to in 7784
Roman numeral 13.
it used to say that the um as you can
see in the bill
it references 172 in the eternal revenue
code it used to say 172
um in effect in 1996. and that's
important because under the tax cuts and
jobs act in 2017 when under the um
federal law we had a whole bunch of tax
cuts
one of the one I call a revenue raiser
was limiting the amount of the net
operating loss under federal law and so
basically what that meant was a business
that has nll is that they used to be
able to utilize against their income
they now had this cap they just put in
the 80 cap and so
by us adopting for 172 purposes the 18
code we've now conformed to that
provision
and so we are stuck with that unless we
kind of decide we don't want that
anymore and again that could change if
the federal government says well we're
going to cap it at 50 we'd be tied to
the Internal Revenue code so it's really
what you want to do
[Music]
um
I'll also say under the same tax cuts
and jobs act in 2017 when they put in
this 80 cap they also changed the carry
forward period
how long a business can use their net
operating losses from 20 years to an
indefinite carry forward provision and
so that's important at least they did
that right they put in a cap but they
said we'll let businesses carry forward
their nols indefinitely
we would have adopted that as well
because we're adopting the 18 code for
172 purposes but the reason why we don't
adopt that provision is when you look at
our statute under 77 A4 Roman numeral 13
we explicitly have a 10-year carry
forward period as well as we have a 10
million dollar cap so we have these
other I'll call
less than favorable issues
and so at least under the federal law
not that I would Advocate it but again
when they put in this 80 cap again they
changed the carry forward from 20 years
to indefinite we can't we don't adopt
that because we explicitly have a
10-year carry forward so we're not only
getting stuck with the 80 limitation we
still have this 10-year carry forward
and we still have a 10 million dollar
cap so that's really just some context
that I think is important
um but I don't want to kind of lose
sight of the big picture here which is
how this law is going to work going
forward
um
it so I think the best thing to do is
let me walk you through an example and I
think it'll help illustrate the issue
and so my example it's pretty basic but
I really wanted to drive home the point
here excuse me so if you have a business
in New Hampshire and in year one maybe
it's a startup company or not but if if
you have a business it could be small or
large and it loses money so my example I
have two examples I should say the first
example is how the law used to walk
right up into 2022 so it changes in
2022. and then the second example is how
it now works going forward
and so if you have a company that loses
300 000 in my example in year one and
then make 150 000 over the next three
years you can see cumulatively that they
would make 150 000 Over a four-year
period
now just kind of step back and so what
the yellow deduction is meant to do is
it says okay in year one my business
loses money it could lose a hundred
thousand dollars or 300 000 whatever the
number is and then you get two it starts
to turn the corner things get better so
it makes a little bit of money so it
makes a hundred fifty thousand dollars
so what the law had always been was okay
well will that because income goes up
and down we'll let that business take
that 300 000 loss and carry forward
until they use it and then they'll stop
paying taxes and so in 2022 under my
example they can use 150 of that 300 000
loss next year they make another 150. so
as of the end of three years they break
even they use the remainder of that loss
150 000. now they have no more nol
deduction left and then whatever they
make they pay taxes on so they make 150
in 2024 and they stop paying taxes
that's kind of the big picture and
to me that makes sense because that
business isn't starting to pay taxes and
still they've stopped making a
cumulative amount of money I mean it
would be really unfair that you sit
there and say okay well if you lose 300
000 in the year one and you make 150 000
in year two you're still down you still
lost money since you've been in business
but we're going to make you pay taxes
that's what the law change does and you
can see that in the second example what
now happens and you can see under
example two I put it in bold the less of
those are the key words
that same business loses 300 000 in the
year two it starts to make some money so
it makes 150. now unlike the first
example
they can only deduct that deduction is
limited to the lesson of the carryover
so 300 000 or 80 percent of their income
in that year so eighty percent of the
income in 2022 is 120 000 so the lesson
of is a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars so they can only deduct 120 000
even though they have a 300 000 and a
while sitting on their books they can
only because the government said we're
going to put eighty percent of the cap
they can only deduct 120. so they end up
paying tax on thirty thousand dollars in
year two
again you have a business that it could
have lost a million dollars in year one
make fifty thousand dollars in the year
two this is going to make them stop
paying taxes in year two even though
they just lost a million dollars and
they make fifty thousand dollars in year
two because they have this cap and so if
you just do that math across in year
three again so now they had a 300 000
nol they used 120 that leaves 180 same
thing the less of 120 or 180 well it's
120 so then they pay taxes again so at
the end of year three they've only
broken even yet they've paid taxes on
sixty thousand dollars their income and
then in the year four they use the
remainder and the remained is 60 and
because 60 is the lesser of the the cap
of 120 in my example then they get to
use it all so you can kind of just see
in both examples they use the three
hundred thousand dollars but it's capped
in the second example so they have to
use it over a long period of time they
start paying taxes earlier so that's
really the takeaway here that
um
I guess it's kind of a fundamental
question is that what we want that a
business loses money and then it can
lose a million dollars and then it makes
ten thousand dollars the next year
they're going to have to pay taxes on
that ten thousand dollars because they
can't use all their nol and so again it
could change it's 80 now it's a
government if the IRS says it's 50 to 90
would be tied to it so the bill
basically just strikes this limitation
and goes back to the way it used to be
um I also just wanted to point out and I
let the dra speak to the fiscal note but
and I don't know how the dra calculated
and again I don't want to speak for them
and they can clarify it but
I'm not sure if they took like the total
amount of nols on their books and then
multiply times 80 and and use that as
kind of a base but to me there's no
issue here at all really I mean I know
I know maybe it's prudent to try to have
a worst case fiscal note
but I don't even think and I would
understand that but I don't think it's
realistic at all because
if you just think about it first of all
I think the dra would agree this is the
cap so of the population of nols in the
state
a lot of businesses this isn't even
going to matter because they're going to
be under the cap if a business loses 50
000 in year one and it makes 500 000 a
year too they're going to be under the
cap the Cap's not going to apply because
80 of 500 000 is 400 000 so they're
going to be well under the cap so by
just looking at the NLOS on the on the
dra's books
some population isn't even going to be
affected by that at all because they're
already under the cap it's only if
they're if they're subject to the cap
because of the where the income is
like my example and in that case it's
just a timing issue you can see how it
just plays out it's whether you use it
until you stop making money again or you
just put a cap on it and you stretch it
out longer so it's a timing issue it's
not a permanent issue and again I know
no one can project taxable income and
all that it's kind of a shot in a dock
but it it's not a prominent issue that's
really the key Point here it's a timing
issue it's when the state's allowing a
business to take their nols under
example one how it used to be or now to
this cap
so I think
I think that's really everything that I
had and I'd be happy to answer any
technical questions or any questions at
all
I actually have a question because we
don't operate in a vacuum here in New
Hampshire so what are other states doing
did everyone else take a line with the
IRC new IRC code or yeah it's a good
question thank you I it's I would say
it's all over the place I mean again we
we we're tied to the 18 code many states
have a low income for me so they're tied
to the most recent code so this is at
the 18. there's been changes since the
18 code we had the chaos activists
change things
um
but again
so that's one factor that tied to
different codes I'd say
um some states are adopting it and then
some states are not adopting a
decoupling from it I'd also say that
again other states don't have a 10
million cap they also don't have a
10-year carry forward so if they're
going to adopt the 80 Captain they're
probably adopting the
um indefinite carry forward provision
because it's part of the same section
172 under the 2018 code it's the same
thing so so it kind of is all over the
place
I see some hands up over here
representative Ames did you have a
question
thank you and thank you for your
testimony
um I'm wondering also
um sort of it's this is a follow-up from
the chairs question
um I'm wondering also about what
Congress said when they chose to provide
for an indefinite period as well as an
80 limitation
um in support there's there's usually a
committee report on changes like this
and whether you've seen that whether you
could provide that to us it would be
helpful to have background on why
they made these choices
right I don't I can't speak to that
maybe I can find a committee report
um
right I I again my own kind of what I've
read is basically many people saw that
as a revenue raiser because the tax cuts
and jobs Act of 2017 logically decreased
taxes and so this raised Revenue
um
again it I guess it stabilizes the
revenue social Mr state right because if
you look at my example again everything
else being equal it's great for the
state because they get this profit
coming in taxes being paid a lot earlier
than it would otherwise be be paid and
so that's really to me the fundamental
question you can see in the year two in
you're making this business pay taxes on
thirty thousand dollars even though
cumulatively over the two years they've
lost money that's kind of the
fundamental question the state will
otherwise get it just it's just a matter
of when it's after they used a net
operating losses in order versus having
this cap
um yeah and it's right with the
indefinite carry forward Parisian again
I'll see what I can find my my kind of
take on that was It was kind of
part and parcel that
they put a cap on it but they they
loosen their 20 to carry forward to
indefinite
again we would have otherwise adopted
that but we have a specific provision
that only says a 10-year carry forward
is allowed
other questions yes representative
spilsbury
thank you madam chair
um you mentioned that Congress has made
further changes in the Internal Revenue
code since 2018 but have they made any
changes regarding the nols
um so
I mean they have yes and no it's it's
so the 70 is still what they did
basically was we they put this in place
as a 2017 so it was going to be the law
as of 18 but then we had the pandemic
and so when the epidemic hit they had
the cares act and so for 18 19 and 20
they they
um temporarily suppress the 80
limitation they said it was 100 again
for those three years now in 2021
forward it's back to 80 percent so
so the law currently is the same as what
we've adopted last year by conforming to
the 18th vote right so right so now
because we're in 2022 year it's 80 right
okay thank you so much for your
testimony
I'm sorry representative
do you have a question
um Do You Remember
this came from the Senate
do you remember how they were uh why
they were
defending this in particular and or how
they did it here which I'm afraid I've
forgotten
so so I'm I'm gonna go on and I'm here
so what I recall was right so this was
Senate bill 435.
um so this was the bill that fixed the
apportionment issue which was a great
fix
um
in that when that build language changed
I think I don't know maybe it just
inadvertently they just they saw a 1996
reference date to section 172 and they
just someone just Struck it
um
and that had an impact maybe it wasn't
recognized immediately but anytime you
change the reference to the Internal
Revenue code it's going to have an
impact and so that was kind of a call a
lesser Fallout
and so it it just wasn't the focus of
the bill the focus of the bill was to
fix the double proportionment issue
follow up
on just to the chair and I remember
having this particular argument last
time and then 19 of us voted the way it
went
on I don't remember any more than that
if we have records
that we could look at or if somebody
behind us is going to talk to that that
would be helpful
absolutely we will ask for that
thank you so much I don't have any more
pink cards we do have someone here from
the dra did anyone want to ask Keen Wong
some questions
yes um if you just think fill out a pin
card when you get a moment
good morning my name is Keane mingual
tax policy Council from the Department
of Revenue we prepared the fiscal note
for this bill and the department does
not have a position on this Bill I'm
here to answer any questions that the
committee may have
representative fellows has a question
thank you
um when I look at this
you know I'm new on this committee I
don't know very hardly anything about
this but it seems to me just logically
the reason for having a cap of 80
percent or some kind of cap has to do
with trying to manage your revenue
streams because that prevents
with the 80 percent uh cap in there it
prevents
your revenues from taking a really
drastic dip in some year that where many
of the businesses might be impacted you
know covet or you it didn't turn out
that way with covid but something could
happen that would cause that is is that
the rationale that would be used to have
a cap versus no cap
about the period just the cap yeah I
believe that that could be a reasonable
reason for that because as you as you
explained it when there's an 80 cap um
as the previous testimony as well the
businesses will not be able to claim the
maximum 100 for that particular year uh
that remaining um carry the remaining
unclaimed NL that does not claim for
that particular year will be carried
over to the next year for claim if
there's taxable income in that for that
next year so in that first year the
impact on revenues for uh for for the
state would not be as stressed yes
you're right
representative only has a question
thank you so given what actually
happened where the federal government
bailed us all out and on
business most businesses got back on
their feet a lot faster than we were
anticipating the did this 80 percent
would have artificially increased our
revenues
um
I I wouldn't I'm not because that 80 is
for tax years 22 onwards so that impact
has not been seen yet though
uh
other questions from the committee
represents Pillsbury
thank you madam chair
would you agree that the effect of the
80 percent limit
is basically to help smooth out the
cyclicality of uh both the tax burden of
the corporate taxpayer as well as the
revenue of the State of New Hampshire
um I believe that it's more of the
latter like like what representative
fellows was alluding to that it sort of
smoothens out the uh the effects on the
Rev on the state revenue side but um as
the previous testimony mentioned I think
uh since the if the on the business side
if the taxpayers were able to claim uh
the full amount for that first year
they'll just claim the full amount for
the first year so there's probably no
um I guess
um and that 80 would stretch it out in
that way yes
okay thank you very much okay and I just
also wanted to point out
um during our fiscal note when we
prepared it uh just wanted to point out
that um if this bill was to pass there
was some uh language in there that we
felt that um
to apply the uh the 80 uh the removal of
the 80 limitation to other business
organizations other than the C uh other
than the C Corp so I think that
additional language needed to be
included in in the uh in the bill as
well
so that all business organizations no
matter what form would enjoy that um
that uh elimination of the the income
limit cap
representative
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking our question so um
you are saying right now the way the
bill is written it's not covering all
businesses uh that is our read on the on
the current bill yes it's only for a c
corpse right now and then follow up
that was my fault okay good awesome
all right yeah representative Morris
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question so with this change
does it impact taxpayers that do not own
businesses
so right now as it's written it's only
for C corpse so um right but I'm saying
does this shift what I'm asking is does
it shift the tax burden in any way
it does not shift the text burden no
it's okay it's only
um so it's so each particular taxpayer
would have their liability and it won't
shift that burden to another
taxpayer I'm not sure if I'm
answering your question no you've
answered it thank you
representative Albi
thank you but if you're a startup and
you registered as a C Corp and you lose
000 the first year
on and the second year you make the 150
and
Celia's uh
uh example
and you have to pay
thirty thousand in on thirty thousand in
taxes
on hasn't that shifted a burden to you
because you're going to have to borrow
that money too if you're still starting
up
I I guess
um in in my mind the shifting of burden
is Shifting the tax burden from one
taxpayer to another taxpayer I think in
your example representative there's only
one taxpayer there's no shifting of
Burden from one taxpayer to another
taxpayer so I'm just not okay my
apologies okay
okay thank you very much I see a
researcher here were you able to look up
the history the legislative recent
legislative history on this topic
can we put it on the record would you
mind coming up and so we can hear you a
little bit better thank you
the bill that passed last year was SB
435 relative to the net operating loss
carryover under the business profits tax
and I have
um the bill and the dras fiscal note
quick guide
along with the majority of minority
reports that I could produce copies for
the whole committee if that would be
helpful
thank you that would be helpful for us
to just refresh our memories and what
happened
okay
all right is there anyone else who would
like to speak on House Bill 450.
yes
the former senator
fragdon do you have a pink card
excellent thank you
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record uh Peter
Bragdon recovering state senator uh here
representing the greater Nashua Chamber
of Commerce of which Mr siglio is is a
member and just for some background of
the discussion prompted this in me that
the Senate Bill 435 was an important
business Bill last year that dealt with
a double apportionment issue which I
don't fully recollect and understand I
understood it at the time I do not now
but I do recall it was a significant hit
to businesses that were basically paying
more than they should have to pay so the
key thing for all business groups
including the Nashua chamber was the
double apportionment issue and so when
it was discovered at some point in the
process that by switching to the 2018
code it also affects this carry forward
that Jim explained
um it was kind of like almost like it
was too late you know we don't want to
stop this train because it's so
important to fix the double
apportionment problem
um and that was part of the reason I
think it was just it was so close close
to the end so the the underlying bill I
think it was Senate Bill 435 was a very
important business bill and we all
supported it but it seems to have this
uh other consequence as well which is
being addressed now so I hope that helps
provide some context
so just declare be clear uh does the
chamber support this bill as is or would
you also recommend that we extend the
10-year extend the cap
uh the chamber is taking no position on
possible changes to it
um so definitely supportive of the bill
and I think it was pointed out it may
only apply to certain companies and
obviously would want it to apply to any
company so
happy to answer any questions
represent uh all me and then ulery
it's very helpful you've triggered some
memory
memory on
on do you remember some kind of faint uh
idea of uh leaving this part of it in
would reduce our Revenue hit
no my recollection was oh we didn't
realize that was included as part of
what we're doing and but it's too late
to fix it and we don't want to we don't
want to derail the train
which I I completely understand that it
was a very important change that was
made
representative ulery
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question Senator the
question is
under this bill it would look like a
startup business
or actually any business that would have
a net operating loss
would be hit with a tax burden when they
were least capable of meeting that tax
burden
and yet the Chamber of Commerce
is in favor of hurting businesses
I don't know that I understand the
question uh representative that the
chamber supports this bill good thank
you man
well the way this bill looks is that if
they have a net operating loss in the
first year
then they have a net operating loss in
the second year as well as they're
developing their business or they're
recovering from a downturn in business
cycle for for whatever reason
they would still be only able to apply a
certain amount of their money up to the
cap and then would be held liable for
their a tax burden on top of that even
though there was no real
profitability of the company
uh if I'm reading this uh I do not read
it that way I read it as a company will
not have to pay uh taxes on profits
until such time as they actually make a
profit cumulatively it's more of a cash
flow issue for especially small
companies and to be able to uh to have
to pay taxes earlier
um hurts the small businesses so I I
don't agree with your understanding of
the bill although I am not an accountant
uh I'm like Mr yoseglio but that's my
understanding and that's the chamber's
understanding
great thank you for your testimony
thank you
okay is there anyone else like the CPA
Society who would like to speak on this
bill
nope okay uh seeing none we will close a
public hearing on House Bill 450.
thank you
foreign
I currently do not have any pink cards
on House Bill 288 other than the dra
is there anyone here to
talk about that
chair do you want me yes
we will now open the hearing on House
Bill 288 and recognize representative
almei to introduce the bill
thank you madam chair I will fill out
the pink card right after this on I am
introducing House Bill 288 FN relative
to taxation of sole proprietorship
businesses and uh I will take no
questions because
I don't think I agree with him
thank you
is there anyone else here who would like
to say anything about 288 then I will
recognize uh Keen Wong from the dra see
if he has some Intel for us
good morning my name is text policy
counselor for the Department of Revenue
Administration the department does not
have a position on this bill the
department did prepare a fiscal note on
this bill and I'm here to answer any
questions
um on that do you want to just give us a
high level overview of your note and
then we'll see if you have questions
sure thank you as we understand this
bill is to treat the uh single member
LLCs and sole proprietorships as not
business organizations and therefore
exempting those two types from
um BPT as well as bet the department
prepared a fiscal note impact on this uh
the department
has not performed a detailed analysis on
the constitutionality on this this bill
but uh initial thoughts uh it could be
unconstitutional in terms of treating uh
creating a different class of taxpayers
representative ulery
um just for the education this is the
beginning of the the term and there are
some individuals could you refresh my
memory on the deduction or the filing
point the threshold of filing for the
class of a sole proprietor or a single
person LLC
uh for New Hampshire business taxes
there is no distinction between uh the
filing threshold for uh for a single
member LLC or a sole proper type
proprietorship versus C Corps or any
other corporations the following
threshold
for tax year uh 22
for BPT is uh
ninety two thousand dollars for a gross
business income and for tax years 23
through 24 because of the uh
inflation adjustment that's that's done
the gross business income
limitation was a hundred and three
thousand dollars and then for business
Enterprise tax the tax uh the limitation
the gross receipt limitation as well as
the Enterprise Value tax base for tax
years uh 22 was 250 000 and for tax
years from uh 23 through 24 also with
the CBI adjustment is 281 thousand
dollars
a little follow-up follow-up all right
and that also applies to a sole
proprietor yes
anyone who's doing business in New
Hampshire has that entry threshold that
is correct thank you sir I appreciate
that you're welcome representative
thank you madam chair
um
uh Mr Wong I asked I sent you a request
for
um information on what your what you you
did as a fiscal note was solely on the
bet I believe uh the fiscal note was
done solely on uh 11 10 40 NH 1040
filers because the way the
the way to file is the business
the way uh taxpayers need file their
returns their business tax returns in
New Hampshire if uh it depends on the uh
for for single member llc's anyway
um so for sole proprietorship sales file
a 1040 NH 1040 for for BPT and then uh
for uh for their bad returns for smlcs
it depends on the member the type of the
member so if the single member LLC the
single member is a partnership
then that smlc will file a NH 1065.
there's no checkbox to say okay to
identify that this return is a single
member LLC filer
and then if um then if the member the
sole member of the smlc is an individual
then the return that's going to be filed
will be at NH 1040 and once again
there's no check box to indicate on that
return
so that's why the fiscal mode is only
limited to NH 1040s
all right follow-up but does that mean
that we don't have information on
whether these same individuals earned
enough profit that they are also paying
BPT
for um for the um
the question that you asked was um
earlier in the email was uh for bet
filers were they also following BPT and
we did find that um
like 2500 of those bet filers who are
sole Proprietors
bet filers also had BPT liability
out of the Thirteen thousand
yeah so you're now saying I was sorry
follow-up uh you're now saying it was 20
only 25 people had a BPT liability
2500 oh 2500.
that that isn't
clear I think in your response to the
email which I I've copied to everybody
here
so there were 13
000 bad filers were Proprietors and
there were also about 13 000 of them
also had to file a BPT return but from
that BPT return not all of those had a
BPT tax due
only twenty five hundred of that had a
BP to Tech student
thank you okay
thank you very much thank you
okay are there any other folks that
would like to come speak on House Bill
okay seeing none we will close the
hearing on House Bill 288 and we will
take a little bit of a break before we
go into exec session so we can get a
little bit organized so why don't we
come back in about
10 minutes
we'll now open the executive session on
House Bill 60 and the chair will
recognize recognize representative
janigan for motion
thank you madam chair I make a motion to
retain hb60 is there a second
great would you like to speak to your
motion
yes thank you madam chair
um so
I think on this bill we need a little
more time there was a
the day it was introduced the
author mentioned that a constituent was
not available so we don't have all that
testimony and um and I think there's
also we need to just look at how this
could affect the state does this affect
tourism in some way yes other states do
have different fees for different
whether someone's out of state but does
that mean New Hampshire needs to follow
suit is that what we want to do so we
need more time to study this
other discussion
wow that was quick
um before we call the roll I just want
to welcome and introduce you to uh
Richard coulomb who is here filling in
for representative Heinz who could not
make it welcome
okay clerk are you ready to call the
roll
the motion before us is retain house
bill 60. I am ready to call I'll start
with representative janigan
yes representative
representative set yes
represents Pillsbury yes representative
pled votes yes representative colcom
yes representative salty
yes representative Oris Oris
no
representative Rochford
representative Army
representative Ames yes
representative Southworth
not president
okay
okay representative Malloy
representative Schoenberg yes
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes
yes representative elberger yes
representative leapley
yes representative Smith
yes
and the chair
yes okay the vote is 18 to 1 not one not
present
okay the retained motion uh doesn't
actually go to the floor it just means
that we keep that bill in committee and
that we will work again on it in the
fall
okay
great we will close the executive
session on House Bill 60 and now open up
the executive session on House Bill 121
and the chair recognizes representative
All Me for a motion
thank you madam chair uh I moved to
retain HB 121 relative to worldwide
combined reporting for unitary
businesses under the business profits
tax is there a second
second
representative seconds the motion
representative would you like to speak
to your motion yes thank you on this
bill could be extraordinarily important
for New Hampshire and for
for the country uh eventually on but we
need the results of what's going to
happen in the commission that has been
delayed by not being properly staffed
yet we need the Staffing to be completed
quickly and then to allow that
commission to go to work over this
summer so that we will be able to tell
exactly on what it well
we will be able to estimate what it does
to um
our our states on economy and to our
state's tax system thank you
all the discussion representative Ames
thank you
um
you mentioned with respect to their bill
we just retained uh Hospital 60 I think
that we'd return to retain bills like Ed
in the fall I just I understand that but
I I suggest in this case it would be
well to revisit uh what's happening
um
before the summer so that if they're
continue to be delays in the work that I
think most of us feels feel needs to be
done to dig into this complicated issue
will at least know that it's not going
where it should be going or it is
um before it gets to be too late
representative Schamberg and then
representative ulrey
well thank you madam chair
um
some of you may find what I'm going to
say is confusing as I am part of the
worldwide combined reporting Commission
and Prime sponsor of House Bill 121
which I presented to this house Ways and
Means Committee on January 17th my
position on this bill is counter to what
was discussed about retaining House Bill
121 to let the commission do its
research and hear the Public
Presentation by experts on both sides of
the issue and listen to the domestic
company's views about advantages and
disadvantages
this position I'm taking on this bill
today is not a reflection on my good
friend from Charleston serving as chair
of this commission who has undertaken
trying to populate and move this
commission forward
even before representative spilsbury was
elected chair of the honorable Patrick
abrami who was elected as the first
chair but was unfortunately unseated in
the New Hampshire as a New Hampshire
state representative in the last general
election made many efforts to populate
this commission per RSA 78-a colon
23-b
representative abrami spent two months
trying to initiate the formulation of
prospects for this commission though it
was not his responsibility
even though the effective date to report
the commission results to the
legislature is November 1st 2023 there
are still six unpopulated seats to fill
on this commission none of these empty
commission seats is the responsibility
of the new chair of the commission for
the past six months there has been no
movement by those responsible to
nominate and populate the commission as
a member of Ways and Means Committee and
Prime sponsor of this bill I take this
position very seriously when it comes to
tax policies by just allowing the
uncertainty of populating these seats on
the commission to drag on I don't want
the general public or the New Hampshire
business Community to question our
motivation as Ways and Means members if
a tax policy that is presently in place
is fair and on a Level Playing Field it
has been months since the worldwide
combined reporting commission was formed
and is still a struggle to motivate
parties to populate this commission I
find myself concerned about the process
of determining whether those responsible
for populating this commission are
serious of investigating this particular
tax policy
from 1986. that is why I feel I must
vote against retaining this bill so that
an open approach on the concerns raised
by the prime sponsor in this bill can be
undertaken in a timely fashion thank you
madam chair
representative ulrey
uh thank you representative Schomburg
but uh
I will defer to um
Terry um
representative spillsworth
in that
action is being taken to populate the
committee
and I'm not sure exactly where we are as
far as some of the uh other individuals
but I am aware that
um seats are being filled because I just
filled one
thank you representative representative
spilsbury thank you madam chairman
um I understand and sympathize with
representative Schamberg's frustration
uh the good news is that speaker Packard
has in fact filled the vacancy in the
house with representative ulery who I
welcome to the commission
and I would just suggest that the
primary reason for retaining is not the
vacancies or the delay it's simply that
the commission was set on a timetable of
reporting by November 1st so retaining
this bill sinks
this committee with the commission's
ultimate work product
and I think that's worth doing
and I think we would be doing it even if
the commission was fully populated at
this time
representative Doucet did you have a
comment anyone else on this side
okay sing oops sorry there you are sorry
representative liebly thank you
um I just want to uh uh ask a question
if I understand there's a deadline in
November is is there any
timeline to which we might we think that
the commission might start their work
because I understand it's a very
complicated issue and it might be
representative Spielberg could probably
answer that question for you
sure good question as I had mentioned
when I testified on the bill with the
work load that the committee has in
terms of Revenue estimates and Bill flow
there is really no point not to mention
the vacancies in trying to have the
commission meet much before the end of
March with crossover coming about April
6th so I would look for some progress in
terms of our meeting to occur in the
April May time frame and then to be very
much On Target most commissions
are formed with passage of a bill in the
spring and a due date of that November
it just basically puts us back on that
normal timetable
any other comments for discussion okay
seeing none uh the motion before us is
to retain House Bill 121 the clerk will
turn off his phone and call the rolls
turn to retain uh representative Zone
again
yes
representative ulery
representative Doucet yes representative
spilsbury yes representative pledge
votes yes representative uh kilcam
representative sodi
yes
representative orrs yes representative
Rosewood
yes representative Army
yes
representative Ames yes
a representative Southworth is not
present
representative Malloy yes representative
Schoenberg no
representative fellows yes
representative Bolton yes representative
elberger yes representative lippley
yes
representative Smith
yes and the chair
yes okay the vote is 18 to 1 and 1 not
present
so we will retain that bill and see what
the good commission does and go from
there okay we will now close the
executive session on House Bill 121 and
open up House Bill 145 and the chair
recommend recognizes representative
janigan for a motion thank you madam
chair I make a motion to retain
HB 145. is there a second I second
representative Platt seconds uh would
you like to speak to your motion yes
thank you madam chair
um so on this bill we also need to get
some more information
we need to hear from the AG's office
there was a bill last year that
addressed this but whether you know we
we need more complete information is is
I think definite so I think at this
point retaining only makes sense
of the discussion
representative Army
thank you well the bill was the Wayfarer
Bill and it was in four years ago
something like that on
and we have a letter from the Attorney
General's office
about this but uh from the gentleman
that on
Attorney General
for Mela put in charge of this uh area
the Wayfair area and but
um we will go along
I will go along with routine
yeah I think we didn't have a lot of
testimony for this bill so I feel like
we need to hear a little bit more I know
we've got some written materials but it
would be nice to actually hear from some
folks on this uh other other comments on
this matter
okay the motion before us is to retain
House Bill 145 the clerk will call the
roll
yes Madam chair
I'll never be fully ready
um representative janigian yes retained
representative ulery yes representative
Doucette yes representative spilsbury
yes representative plett votes yes
representative uh cocom yes
representative sodi yes representative
orrs
yes representative Rochford yes
representative Almy yes representative
Ames yes representative Southworth not
present
uh representative Malloy
representative Schomburg yes
representative fellows yes what
representative Bolton yes
representative elberger yes
representative leapley
yes representative Smith yes and the
chair
yes
I just make sure my count was right 19 0
and 1 not present
all right so we will retain that bill as
well so we will end this executive
session I wanted to start nice and easy
this way with some simple stuff uh we'll
be scheduling future executive sessions
soon so we now are in uh break time
until 1 15.
thank you very much
well I I did all that electronically in
the last term tool
thank you
good afternoon
the time being 1 15 we will now open the
public hearing on House Bill 486 and
welcome up the prime sponsor
representative Hull
uh come toy sorry I got that wrong
thank you madam chair thank you members
of Ways and Means Committee it's a
privilege to be here before you today my
name for the record is representative
Barbara comtwa Belknap 7's representing
Senator Barnstead in Alton New Hampshire
um I introduced this builds uh this year
uh this was a law that was passed last
session
um
and
it has been brought to my attention that
we're now collect people are not allowed
to register their vehicles if they owe
tolls in another state
um
and there's a lot of problems with this
it creates a hardship on those uh folks
they have to take time out of work now
that they're not allowed to register a
vehicle or they didn't even realize that
they owe tolls until they went to
register the vehicle and now how are you
how are they going to get to another
state how are they going to get back and
forth to work
you know we have other states that
there's no monetary way and then we're
relying on the Postal Service to make
sure they get these notifications
and just in New Hampshire
there are folks when they try and call
Easy Pass it's hours on the phone or if
they go down to the Easy Pass
um place
the office it's a you know minimum
usually an hour just to get heard
if someone's working a regular nine to
five job you're talking taking a full
day off work losing a day's wages to
deal with some of these issues that's
just in New Hampshire
imagine these people having to go to
another state to fix these problems and
then once the problem is fixed then they
have to go to Concord New Hampshire to
get their registration released even if
it's already all their tolls have been
paid
okay that is what's happening in New
Hampshire I don't know how it works in
other states but I would say that we are
much more efficient here than other the
larger States
and if we're experiencing that here with
our own constituency in this state what
do these people what is happening to
people in other states
we don't collect sales tax for other
states we don't do a lot of things but
yet we're going to collect tolls and
we're going to tell people that they
can't register their vehicles their only
means of transportation to get in back
and forth to work
transporting their children to school
this is just wrong on so many levels
I am open for any questions
representative
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
um I'm just trying to think of the
potential unintended consequences I mean
we do other states
help us out whereby what if we can't
collect tolls from somebody
um
I'm saying that backwards it's we're I
mean as soon as we stop doing that we're
going to have the same problem from the
other states not
uh letting us know if
people from New Hampshire aren't paying
their tolls uh thank you representative
janigan for uh for that question and I
would say to you our responsibility is
to our citizens of New Hampshire
not to the citizens of other states
other questions from the Committees
representative fellows
so I'm I'm trying to get um a better
handle on exactly what the problem is
like who who are the people that are
having this issue are they people
who live in New Hampshire
that drive their vehicles through the
Easy Pass in other states when they
don't have a transponder
uh thank you representative fellows for
the question so not everyone has an Easy
Pass not everyone in the state has a
bank account so they can't have an Easy
Pass
but if you're driving in another state
there's no way for you to pay a toll
unless they take a picture of your
vehicle
well then we're relying on the mail to
get that to you and if it doesn't get to
you in a timely manner then you're
tasked with all these excess fees
so you're creating a burden on people if
someone
they take the picture and if someone
moved and didn't change get a chance to
change your license is that bill gonna
ever find how long is it going to take
for that bill to find them
follow up
follow up so so I I could be wrong
because I didn't look it up
but my recollection because I actually
had a constituent that had an issue like
this
um is that if you move you're supposed
to notify
DMV within I think it's 60 days but it
could be only 30. so they would have
your new address so you would get that
notification
thank you representative fellows for
that yes but if that bill is due in 10
days now you're you're tasked with
excess fines and fees
let's see some other hands that
representative all me
thank you madam chair on it does not
seem to me that we're talking about the
toll practices of the State of New
Hampshire we are talking about the toll
practices of the States of uh
Massachusetts Vermont Rhode Island Maybe
Florida for all I know probably Florida
on and
they should be on
applying the law in
in a way that does not overly burden the
person that ran their toll booths
on
and if they are not we can't do much
about it except to extinguish the entire
network of collaboration
uh isn't it so that's what you're asking
for between the states which allows us
to stop people from on running our toll
booths with impunity which they would be
able and know how to do if we pass this
bill isn't that so
thank you for the quest question
representative Ami I am not sure I mean
I understand that there are people out
there
that willfully break the law every day
and that is their intent
and if that's their intent they have no
intention of paying any tolls whether
they have to register a vehicle or not
I'm not talking about those people I'm
talking about law-abiding citizens that
we're putting an undue hardship on that
are trying to provide for their families
that have no recourse How do they
satisfy something if they have a problem
in as you said Florida do they have to
go to I mean I'm not sure what the
recourse is but I know here in New
Hampshire it is long Waits on the phone
and a long wait at the office
and not only that is even if you do pay
your tolls and you are paid up to date
you then do not just have your vehicle
registration reinstated you then have to
go to Concord DMV
and wait in line again
so I ask you I think this affects
the people
that have the hardest time
in our state
all right follow up but then we're going
to try to get some new other faces okay
go ahead
um brief follow-up done but your doesn't
your bill will do the opposite of this
it says that we should not
comply with requests to block
registrations from other states that
have been
treating the the people that used to
live in them or that drove through them
badly
represent only I'm having a little bit
of hard time could you just repeat that
question for me please yes
um
what you're asking here
is that the commissioner shall not
suspend any of the registrations of
owners in violation of reciprocal toll
collection enforcement agreements that
means that you are asking him to not
deny the registration
on for people who committed violations
in other states not in ours that is so
we're talking about people who had Pro
have problems in other states not in
ours that is correct this has nothing to
do if you owe tolls to the state of New
Hampshire citizens owing tolls to the
state of New Hampshire that is
absolutely correct
thank you
oh representative Platt yes
representative comp toy thank you for
taking my question if I mispronounce
your last name you know it'll get me
perfectly you pronounced it perfectly
okay thank you what if people don't pay
their tolls here
do they get notices in the mail do they
and do they have to go to clean it up
before they get registered here they
have to go to Concord
thank you representative yes they do
they do have to go to not only clean up
their tolls here but then they do have
to go to Concord to get their vehicle
registration reinstated
and as I said we're relying on the mail
to make sure people are getting these
notices in a timely manner
representative Spielberg has a question
thank you madam chair
I think this follows up very much from
representative plett's question
given
the arguments you've made which I
totally sympathize with
uh why are we making a distinction
between
those tolls that have been incurred
while driving through another state
versus those tolls that are not paid at
home
so I mean just speaking for myself I
voted against this bill in the last term
but you're only trying to reverse a
portion of the problem and how do we
make that distinction thank you
representative spillsberry my original
intent was to reverse it all but I was
told that if I did that I would
dismantle the Easy Pass system so I
figured that probably wouldn't be very
popular
thank you
representative Malloy has a question
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question I'm if you could
please help me understand your
definition of timely manner
uh thank you representative Malloy well
if you have a toll
say coming from Massachusetts
and you know the toll has to be paid
within 14 days
and you're relying on the mail and you
don't pay that toll in 14 days then
you're charged late fees
and other fees and say you never got
that mail because somebody else you
didn't even realize that maybe someone
borrowed your car and they went through
Massachusetts it wasn't even you driving
so you just didn't even pay attention to
it
then you go to register your vehicle in
the state of New Hampshire where you
live
where you've been abiding by everything
and you find out you can't register your
vehicle for an unpaid toll in another
state
representative
ugh drawing a blank on how to say it a
Rochford thank you thank you thank you
madam chair and and I thank you
representative I think you may have
answered my question
um
going back this really kind of getting a
better understanding of reciprocity so
the way I'm understanding this is you've
got somebody in New Hampshire that
breaks a law in Florida
but they're being punished in New
Hampshire for a law being broken in
Florida
um so thank you representative for that
and yes that is exactly what is
happening so if I could follow up on
that
so we're speaking about tolls here are
there any other examples where New
Hampshire citizens can be I mean
obviously you can
you know commit a felony but I'm
thinking you go through a stop sign in
Florida and they take a picture of your
license plate are are those instances
do do people in New Hampshire run the
risk of losing the ability to register a
vehicle in New Hampshire for other types
of reciprocity
Arrangements uh thank you for the
question uh honestly I can't answer that
question and the reason this bill was on
my radar was when it passed last year of
which I also voted against
um and I just thought it was egregious
that we would do this to our own
citizenry
representative Schoenberg
thank you madam chair I when I was
looking at the Dre fiscal note is the
number correct down there that
there were just 88 vehicles
that fell under this uh
reciprocity agreement last year or the
year before or
uh thank you representative chamber I'm
not sure you know dra has a better
records than I do
first time questions no more first time
representative all me did you want to
ask a question again okay could I just
make a mention to the chair this is not
a dra fiscal note this is a
transportation and safety fiscal note
because they are the ones who keep that
data
and just so you know we have a
representative from the New Hampshire
dot who will be speaking to us that
maybe can answer some questions and
hands up on this side yes representative
spilsbury
so a different angle on the reciprocity
um
what does New Hampshire do when a
Florida resident driving a car with
Florida plates goes through a toll and
doesn't pay in New Hampshire
ripens feels very honestly I do not know
I wasn't looking into what happens to a
Florida resident I'm only concerned with
New Hampshire residents
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you madam chair
okay well now represent recognize
representative hole come on up
good afternoon representatives for the
record representative Hull serving the
towns of Dunbarton hooks at Allenstown
and epsom
here before you to support House Bill
and I guess
although there's there's context
relative to 260 RSA 263 56-f
I think it makes sense to have a little
bit of an understanding of what happens
when your vehicle registration
privileges have been suspended and
in part two the it goes on the director
shall pursue into RSA 541 right create
rules regarding reinstatement privileges
250 dollars is the first fine
it goes up for a second offense at 500
and then a thousand dollars for a third
and subsequent offenses
so what we're talking about is
potentially denying someone the ability
to register a car
and then New Hampshire enforcing a
penalty at 250 dollars from potentially
something as simple as a mist or failure
to read of an Easy Pass going down while
you're visiting some other state
our constitution is pretty clear under
part first article 18 penalties to be
proportional to the offenses
I'm not sure a we should be the toll
collection agency for the rest of the
country but more importantly if we are
the penalty section should be more in
line with the offense
than they are today and I think that's
the root cause here is we're suspending
the the registration privileges
potentially denying someone the ability
to get to work I would consider that an
overly harsh penalty
for something as simple as a missed fine
here's a good example you're coming home
um from Maine over the weekend your
transponder seems to be working fine and
you miss the tolls sorry you missed the
exit to get on 101 headed west and lo
and behold you're now into headed into
Massachusetts
um and you end up racking up a couple
other tolls but one of those doesn't
read you don't realize it doesn't read
your battery on your 14 year old guilty
transponder
um has finally died and although it
didn't happen in Massachusetts it did
happen in New Hampshire a few times
um
they fail to notify you
um I don't know if any of you are
getting house calendars late my last one
was five days after it was sent out I
only live 11 miles from here okay
relying on the United States Postal
System to deliver mail in a timely
manner is not a given although it is a
constitutional requirement it is not a
given thing that we can trust in 2023
so I would ask that you see that their
true cost right yes there's a revenue
impact to this bill that's why it's here
and not in transportation but more
importantly
this is about proportional penalties
relative to the offense and I think the
proportional penalties right right now
of denying someone the ability to
register a car
and then forcing them to spend 250
dollars to get their registration back
is way out of line relative to someone
failing to make right to pay a fine
let's say it's malicious I'll go to the
corner case that they maliciously they
knowingly drove to DC and back and chose
not to leave their transponder in their
window and they racked up thirty dollars
worth of charges both ways for all the
tolls and they tell everybody from
Massachusetts all the way down we're
just not going to pay it
I don't even think in that case for the
sixty dollars of failed tolls our
current punishment makes sense
I think there needs to be a better way
if we're going to do reciprocity between
states that's fine
but I don't know that we should be the
business in the business of collecting
tolls for the rest of the country nor
should they be in the business of
collecting our tolls I think
fundamentally we've created a problem by
this interstate agreement I would ask
that you would support this bill to stop
this thank you
would you be open to questions sure do
my best other questions over here
representatively
thank you for taking my question
I'm wondering if you could just help me
understand your testimony I'm looking at
line 10.
um
so it says the director shall notify the
owner in writing by first class mail
that the owner's Motor Vehicle
Registration privileges for the vehicle
driven in violation of RSA 23631 are
suspended as of the date which is 30
days from the date of notification
and less the toll in any administrative
fees assessed by the Department of
Transportation are paid So currently
that fee is 250 no
so that fee kicks in after the
registration has been suspended
so
if header they have failed to pay a toll
and they respond by paying the toll and
any administrative fees then they're all
set they don't lose their registration
so it correct if the if if that was the
important element in that sentence if
they received a notification
given that we're still relying on the
United States Postal System to deliver
some of this because that is the system
of record right now and there is not
certain it's not like it's a registered
mail or something that's going to be
traceable this is typically sent through
first class mail by another state to us
it may or may not get to the right
address they may or may have may or may
not have an accurate record in their
database right Easy Pass may have
outdated information there's I could
think of a lot of reasons why that that
particular letter does not arrive at the
individual so now not only have they
missed the first letter notifying them
that they missed a toll then they get a
second letter that says you've missed a
toll and you've been assessed this
additional fine and penalty for failing
to pay the first time
it now kicks it back to New Hampshire so
failure to communicate shouldn't be a
punishment at the 250 level if it was
something like the they were they were
it was a a registered lever letter where
there was right they had to sign the
letter to acknowledge receipt then we
started the Rules start to change at
least the person is aware of what's
going on that's not the case today
representative rodford
thank you madam chair
I'm trying to get if you could help me
with this so what I'm understanding is
someone doesn't pay a toll in Mass a
dollar 75 toll in Massachusetts right
blow it off intentionally or
unintentionally
so that reciprocity means they can't
register a car in New Hampshire so that
takes away their ability to register in
the state of New Hampshire misses out on
revenue from car registrations yeah
right so would you agree with me that
we're actually the state enhancer is the
bigger biggest loser in this
So based on the possibly right based on
the fiscal note that's in the bill it
looks like we might not collect thirty
two thousand dollars assuming that the
dot captured their information correctly
and I'm reading the fiscal note right we
may be a lot of loss where other states
are helping us Force collections but at
the end of the day
um it might affect a car registration it
might affect someone's ability to drive
a car and we have an obligation to make
sure our punishments that we hand out
here within the state are somewhat
compliant with the Constitution and this
is definitely not proportional to the
dollar 75 toll where you're you're
revoking someone's ability to
potentially drive to work the next day
that could be problematic and it kicks
off another series of events right once
you've gone down this path
now you don't have a registered car and
you get pulled over for a police by a
police officer now you're driving an
unregistered vehicle so this just
snowballs into a series of problems over
a toll that is was supposed to be
collected in another state
we're not in the business of doing the
work for the other states as far as I
know we don't really get paid to do the
enforcement for work for the other
states
I understand the desire to have a
reciprocal agreement between States
because it makes it a little bit more
convenient but convenience is not why
we're here we should in fact be
enforcing our laws on our citizens and
not trying to enforce the loss of other
states on our citizens
representative Ames has a question
thank you I'm here
um
yeah I think you mentioned uh an
interstate agreement and uh I don't know
whether you meant by that that there is
such a thing but if there is
um maybe you could tell us about about
it and uh then sort of related to that
question is what you know about what
other states have
put into their laws in terms of
enforcement that might be parallel
consistent way they're inconsistent with
what's in this bill and I will say that
you would make a a good point about the
disproportionality of the punishment
that's in here
um whether it's unconstitutional or not
that's a different question but uh yeah
right so by no means an expert on the
toll collection systems for the other 49
states
um so I don't know that I could
effectively answer
or speak to that part of the question
I do think right we as a legislature
should be crafting laws about how we
enforce our laws on our right relative
to our citizens and if someone from
Maine drives through New Hampshire to
Massachusetts and fails to pay our tolls
right we may have our only recourse may
be the next time they're on the roads
and an officer spots them and realizes
that plate hasn't been
is owing it owes money that right when
they pull them over right they were
speeding they pull them over and say oh
you're owing money now now that's now
it's time to collect that fee that might
be the only recourse available it's very
difficult to enforce our laws on State
on residents who spend a very limited
amount of time traveling through the
state
you're okay with more questions sure
okay representative Platt has a question
yes what is the cost to the DMV
to suspend registration
and then to re uh activate the
registration is is that anywhere near
250 do you know uh I do not that's a
great question I I would ask that you
would ask the person who signed up from
the dot to speak that's supposed to
speak after me that same question
because I don't know what the cost is it
does seem like that's a that's a fairly
Hefty fine relative to what we're
talking about
representative elberger has a question
thank you madam chair
um I'm curious about who sets the fees
for penalties
and why we're not talking to them about
changing those fees
so
in RSA 263 56 Dash F right we set the
penalties for a suspended registration
in Roman numeral two sections one two
and three relative to the late payments
and the penalties that I'd have to dig
into I'm sure we probably established a
maximum penalty somewhere in statute or
gave authority via rules to the
department to be able to do this for
assigning penalties for late payment
and I don't know what the current one is
um I I had a similar experience when I
had to deal with a transponder that was
14 years old I was one of the early
adopters and it recently died about last
last year the year before and there was
something like 30 charges that had
racked up in a month because the
responder wasn't working and I drove up
to Concord and spent a fair amount of
time and straightened it all out
there was some penalty associated with
it because their data was old and they
said you know we should just give you
new transponders for all your cars
because you're bound to have this
problem on your other vehicles in a
relatively short period of time so I
ended up getting four new transponders
for our family
I I don't know who sets it but typically
in statute there is a we the legislature
sets a maximum I just think that the
maximum for this particular section is
wrong and I don't think we should be
enforcing other states laws
are we okay representative Olney has a
question
thank you on
if we passed this
we would be relieving
our citizens of
on paying penalties on their violations
in other states but not within our own
state
which you've been using as an example of
unreasonableness on
why would we want to do that just to
leave it to the other state ones so
let's start with not being the law
enforcement agency for the other 49
states and then while this bill is in
this committee maybe the right thing to
do after you speak to the member
speaking after me is readjust the
penalties so they're more in line with
something that would be reasonable
because I could make a convincing
argument that we should truncate the
last zero for all the current penalties
from 25.50 to 100.
um versus the current 250 500 and a
thousand and it would be more in line
with failure to make payment on a dollar
charge driving down the highway
representative orrs has a question
thank you madam Karen thanks for taking
my question so what a possible fix be to
amend this bill so that we not only
reduce the fees that you've just
mentioned but also the start the clock
when they've signed off on a registered
letter notifying them that they have a
deficiency I I I think that would be a
great solution to some of the problems
that we're seeing because failure to
notify creates this
this Snowball Effect of problems for the
person that they may not be a real they
they may not be aware of sorry I'm
losing my voice
follow-up thank you madam chair more of
a statement just than that
I don't get the uh paper calendar
anymore because it takes about eight
days to get to my house
that's a problem and uh recently I've
gone through the toe boost before I got
my little orange transponder and I got a
bill with my picture saying you owe
money and I'm like gee I thought it was
working they're saying oh it does still
work so yeah we do have some issues
there
thank you very much for your testimony
and for your patience no problem thank
you great okay uh let's recognize John
Corcoran from New Hampshire dot come on
up
good afternoon Madam chair and members
of the committee
the turnpike system operates as an
Enterprise fund when all the revenue
collected in the system must be used on
a system
the revenue is collected to pay for our
operation and maintenance our debt
service our renewal and replacement
program and our Capital program which
follows the state's 10-year program
all revenue on the system is put back
into the system reduction in Revenue
ends up creating delays in our Capital
program
as you've heard we we operate on the
Easy Pass system the Easy Pass system
consists of 35 toll agencies through 19
States
this provides a seamless efficient
effective way to collect tolls for
in-state and out-of-state
residents
the users on the system are supposed to
pay the toll at the time as the time
they pass through the toll there are a
variety of options they can pay the toll
when they are fail the paid at all
incurs enough significant number of
violations they are faced with
suspension of their registration
this is the total enforcement
method of in place and it is infected
effective
New Hampshire residents are faced the
constant consequences of suspension of
the vehicle registration
for failure to pay tolls and mass in
Maine are also are faced with the
vehicle suspension for fail to pay New
Hampshire tolls
we were able to collect
from the mass and Main violators because
of this reciprocity or I'm sorry
respical toll agreement we have in place
the department opposes HB 486 which will
eliminate the reciprocity toll
collection enforcement agreement with
mass of Maine which has been in place
since 2011.
this presents a problem for the toll
system of enforcement of toll violators
from Maine and mass in other words we
will not be able to collect tolls from
Main and mass and they will just be able
to ride through through our system free
to try to explain how this process works
from the lane
as a person passes through electronic
tolling without a transponder our
violation system takes a picture of
their license plate
the transactions and images from the
from the lane system go to our Easy Pass
back office vendor
they go through and they view the images
and they get the plate State the plate
number and the plate type
and what that allows them to do is we
send out a file to the DMVs mass in
Maine New Hampshire and five other
states to get the owner of the vehicles
name address
so we can send them an invoice
we typically send first invoice we sent
out they have 30 days to pay
if they don't pay that invoice they get
a second invoice and they have another
30 days to pay that invoice is actually
pink so it stands out more to get their
attention
and if they don't pay that invoice we
sent out a violation notice which they
have another 30 days to pay
now before we can put somebody in DMV
hold the suspension of the registration
they have to collect up to there has to
be 10 transactions where they were at a
violation level notice we can't just do
it on one transaction they have to have
up to 10.
and before we even send somebody to DMV
hold we reach out to the customer again
in a letter from the Department of
Transportation and offering them a
settlement to pay before we send them to
DMV which they would get their
registration suspended they get 30 days
to pay that settlement if they don't pay
then we get we send them to the DMV and
DMV puts the registration in suspension
or potential suspension DMV sends them
out a letter and gives them 30 days to
pay
and then if they don't pay the
registration is suspended
the registration owner of these vehicles
gets several notices
we're typically not dealing with people
with 10 transactions we're dealing with
several hundreds of transactions people
over 500 in tolls
um these obituary offenders get a lot of
mail and they get every they get first
invoice second device violation for
every time we're sending these out to
them
um to give you an idea of how many
images are back office vendor is
reviewing in November there was 1.3
million images that they reviewed of
license plates of vehicles who went
through the toll plaza where we didn't
have we didn't collect an Easy Pass
transponder
of those images 51 of New Hampshire 24
were mass and seven percent were mean
out of the other states it was that went
from 1.3 percent to to almost nothing
um and that's why we have the
reciprocity agreements which is mass and
Maine our neighboring states because
they're the majority of the customers
who fail to pay their toll
and presently our DMV whole process with
mass and Maine we are only limit to send
20 holds a month to them and that's
because it's a manual effort
um currently the hold files have
increased over the past three years due
to covid and also electric electronic
tolling
for Mass they are the more I'll say we
have more holes with mass than Maine
and in 2020 there were 9 000 holds
created
2022 there were 14 000 holds created
of those three years we had an average
paid about 2500 paid and that was
approximately eighty thousand dollars in
tolls
um still outstanding in mass and a
three-year average is like 11 000 holds
and that's about 228 000 dollars in
tolls that is mainly because we have
that 20 20 per month limit
Maine is a little less main we have
around 2500 holds in 2020 up to
3500 in 2022.
the average for those three years we had
500 holds paid and there was about 11
000 tolls
um and then the outstanding holds for
them is around three thousand it's only
ninety five thousand dollars in tolls
um we are working with mass and Main to
try to automate the system instead of
making it manual so we could send more
holds out and go after the the ones that
are still outstanding
for the reasons above the department
opposes the HBO 486 for this
discontinuation so the risk processity
agreements with mass and Maine
especially due to the loss of Revenue
and not treating New Hampshire residents
similar to the violators from other
neighboring states with the suspension
of registration
that concludes my testimony and I'm
happy to answer any questions
thank you for your testimony
representative
yes do you have that testimony in
writing
um no these are my notes we can
would you be kind enough to share those
notes yes yes it was very helpful you
gave us a lot of great data points that
I think we'd like to think about
uh I see a bunch of hands over here
representative Malloy did you have a
question okay representative Britain did
you have a question
yes thank you madam chair
um there's a couple couple of quick
questions once what are the other five
states that are included with mass Maine
and New Hampshire
um we also do address lookup with uh
Connecticut Vermont
Rhode Island New York and New Jersey
also ask
um what kind of punishments they might
do with shirkers of out-of-state tolls
similar to New Hampshire or what
um
the only only ones I know with is mass
in Maine and New Hampshire were the ones
who have the risk of process agreement
where we're allowed to suspend the
registrations
um like with New York if we send
invoices out to them and if they don't
pay it just it just sits there we don't
have a reciprocity agreement with them
and typically
it's just our neighboring states because
they're the I'll say the the biggest
customers who don't pay the toll
you know the other states it's a lot
lower are the invoices that we send out
to
like somebody was talking about Florida
we don't go out and get sending voices
to Florida sometimes it costs you more
money to just create that invoice and
and pay for the DMV lookup and send it
out to that customer in Florida
oh
okay I think I saw more hands over here
representative has a question thank you
madam Chan thank you for taking my
question
um
I I guess I'm I'm a little confused your
testimony stated that if if this
component and the way I read this
proposed legislation it talks about the
enforcement end of things relative to
suspending a registration but you're
saying in the reciprocity agreement that
if we were to suspend this component we
wouldn't be able to collect tolls from
neighboring states with the Easy Pass
transponder
um with any Easy Pass transponder we
collect tolls it's the people who don't
have a transponder who are going through
you know with no
um transponder and we're sending
invoices to them we still the in the
risk process agreement gives us the
enforcement of DMV hold you know to
suspend their registration so people
will pay if you don't have that you know
there's no strong arm behind that to get
them to pay
follow up just a follow-up I believe he
testified that there were over a million
of
of uh vehicles that went through the
toll that did not have or did not
register an easy pass those were there
was a 1.3 million of images our vendor
reviewed they usually get two images per
transaction
and I will tell you some of those at
least 50 percent of those images end up
being come in image tolls and what that
is that's
um an Easy Pass account holder who might
not have had their transponder mounted
or
um it may be the battery's dead and that
we pick up their license plate and their
license plate is a tie to their account
so we charge their account still that
way
it's just all the images I was trying to
explain that how many are from New
Hampshire Maine and Mass
and and not to belabor this but I I
guess you'd have to look at the language
of the reciprocity agreement but
so is it your opinion and or a testimony
that if
we suspend
this component here as far as suspending
registrations that the other states
Massachusetts and Maine would not
assist the state of New Hampshire
DMV in collection of those outstanding
calls or is there something in that
language in that reciprocity agreement
that allows for that or can you answer
that
the suspending the reciprocity agreement
will still allow us to get address
addresses from Mass and Main DMV to send
out invoices to it's just after these
people they get up to the violation
notice and they still don't pay and
there's up to 10 of them you know when
it goes over 10 then we submit them in
hold and that's sort of the strong arm
so they can't read they have to register
the vehicle
they have to pay the Easy Pass tolls
first
so that's what we'll lose
representative
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question so the concern
um earlier was that
you could unknowingly you know
get a toll that you didn't pay and then
suddenly you can't register your vehicle
but from what you're saying
it's going to take at least 10
of these non-paid tolls until it even
registers until it becomes a problem you
can't register your vehicle they'll
become before that they have ability to
go into DMV hold
you know I'll tell you since the backlog
we have
um somebody with one DMV hold we
are luckily going to touch them over the
next couple years there's so much bigger
um
violators with 10 15 holds
representative fellows has a question
thank you
um I just for people who have suppose
somebody has a transponder and it's not
working correctly
in in their uh New Hampshire person and
do what is the method that you would try
to contact them by do you have emails or
do you only have
um post office addresses if
if a New Hampshire customer is going
through the toll plaza and say I was
mentioning image image tolls if you get
10 image tolls in a row we send out
first we send out a text message if
there's a cell phone on there we send an
email out and then we send a letter out
there's certain like it's I think it's
15 days and 30 days and then
up to 45 days
um I can't as if that's the exact number
but we tried to reach out to them to
tell them and then we say that either
your transponder is dying or you it's
not mounted correctly and we remind them
too when it is an image toll they don't
get the discount too
so
yes do you have any comment about the
250 dollar fine assume you're not that's
DMV business that is DMV I I'm not
exactly sure of Their fines
representative spilsbury
thank you madam chairman
um
which if any of these states uh
suspends the license of their drivers
a failure to pay tolls in New Hampshire
um mass in Maine if
um
if a person in mass is violating New
Hampshire and we get their license plate
and send them all the invoices and stuff
that I mentioned we send it to mass DMV
and then they suspend their registration
to pay New Hampshire tolls it's only
mass and Maine that we're allowed to do
that with
follow-up
so from an enforcement perspective
as opposed to a revenue perspective
which do you think is more valuable to
you your Department's objectives
to induce those other states to suspend
their drivers who are violating while
traveling on our roads
or to suspend our drivers when they're
traveling on their roofs
the
the whole re reciprocity enforcement is
important to us just because and it's
important to mass in Maine too because
typically the highest violators are are
your neighboring states who have tolling
you know a tolling system like Vermont
is not very high
so it is important to us to be able to
when somebody is violating a mass remain
on our system
you know New Hampshire tolls to allow us
to go and do the registration suspension
to mass and then they they do the
similar thing is our New Hampshire does
sends out a letter to them and informs
them and tells them it's New Hampshire
tolls you've got to pay
um and mass does the same thing mass
remain does the same thing with New
Hampshire customers who are driving on
their system
and not paying at all
I'm not sure if I answered your question
or
I'll just characterize it as a
frustrating answer
representative has a question yes thank
you madam chair and thank you for
explaining and I I do look forward to
some some written information because
you've you've provided a lot of
information that I think will be very
helpful to us one one of the things that
you mentioned was that New Hampshire
won't take action unless there's 10
transactions or violations
um so I'm assuming then that that's a
Massachusetts vehicle that's coming here
and violating 10 times before you would
send a reciprocity type action
how many violations does it take Maine
or Massachusetts
for them to take action against one of
our drivers they have to follow the same
rules as us it's all ten we all agree to
that it's all part of the reciprocity
agreement
representative Saudi did you have a
question
yes thank you um if I understand
correctly there's there's nowhere in the
process of getting letters do they get a
certified registered letter saying that
hey wake up
pay this no it's all first class mail no
registered letters
and
representative then representatively
after that why can't we read a SunPass
or a gold pass from Louisiana or
whatever
um we can
um Florida which is the sun pass they
are part of the Easy Pass system now so
we can read them and we do get told we
collect toll from them
through the Easy Pass transponder
and now you can travel
from New Hampshire all the way down the
coast to Florida and use your EZ Pass
representative lippley thank you
um so if I understand your testimony
correctly someone who violates
ten times will get a letter with a
30-day
period within which they can pay a
second letter with another 30 days a
third letter with another 30 days
um they'll get a letter of settlement
saying hey you should pay this and if
you pay this now you know maybe you'll
only have to pay X
um that also has 30 days and then you
send them
um onto the DMV
and then they get a letter from the DMV
which gives them 30 days to pay
so they have 150 days to pay basically
before their registration is suspended
um and these letters I'm assuming are
you're sending them to an address
because the person has registered their
vehicle with their state
and so their address is on on file with
our state so it would only be going to
an incorrect address
if they weren't registered properly with
the state and failed to have their mail
forwarded for example
yes yes you're correct that's how the
process is now thank you there are times
where we'll get
um
you know say the person no longer lives
there they return mail we do not carry
that forward so we wouldn't put anybody
in hold or send out additional
um invoices or violation if
if we don't have the correct address
that was very helpful thank you anyone
else before we yeah representative
Spielberg if I make one more
um
roughly what percentage of the state's
roads and I don't just mean State
highways I mean roads
including locally controlled are covered
by a toll
um the New Hampshire Turnpike system
there's only 83 miles of the turnpike
system and that starts it's on in
Concord Exit 14 93 and it goes all the
way down south to 293 through Manchester
to Effie Evert to the mass border and
then the
um that's called the central Turnpike
the blue star is over on the Spalding
which is like
I mean I'm sorry I-95 which is like 16
miles it goes from Mass to Maine then
the Spalding Turnpike goes from like
Portsmouth Circle it's also known as
like Route 16 and it goes up to Milton
exit so you're confirming my
understanding
which is that it's an almost
infinitesimally small percentage of the
miles I understand they're significant
roads and they're well traveled
so I think the thrust of this bill
has nothing to do with the notices and
the fines it has to do with whether
suspension and revocation of a driver's
license
is a reasonable or a disproportionate
penalty device
so somebody who violates a toll
on that little tiny portion of our
roadways effectively is denied the
opportunity to drive on any of our
roadways or to drive at all is there a
question there I'm sorry uh am I
understanding that correctly
the registration gets suspended yes
thank you
if they don't pay uh yeah
do you have a little bit more time yes
okay I see a few more hands and I see
his hands over here
did you have any more questions yes
representative Almy has a question thank
you uh what percentage of the revenues
that come into the turnpike system are
tolls
and how much debt have we got in it
and how much
that
our bun
our bond payments right now this is um
it's around 40 million
that we're paying each year
um toll Revenue in fiscal year 20
um two was around 122 million
oh
and then with that we're paying for all
the operation maintenance and projects
follow-up
so on all of the maintenance and
extension of the of the turnpike system
is from the toll money yes everything's
from toll Revenue
thank you very much for your patience
and answering all of our questions I
don't have any other pink cards for
House Bill 486 is there anyone else who
wishes to testify
all right seeing none we will close the
public hearing thank you
okay moving right along I do not have
any pink cards
for houseful five six nine
there's one coming
okay
thank you
yes the best email address would be
house Ways and Means Committee
at ledge.state.nh.us
[Music]
yes that's fine too thank you so much
thank you
I apologize to make you do that
laughs
okay we will now open the public hearing
on House Bill
569 and recognize representative Ames
thank you
just trying to get my papers together
here
okay and
I'm here to speak in support of House
Bill five
six nine
um which I'm sponsor of
and um
I really want to
well first you you have papers in front
of you that I've handed out there should
be three different items I'll point to
them
um
and one of the items is what is
basically the notes that I'll follow in
trying to present this bill the key
elements of
569. what I really want to say at the
very outset is that this bill is
essentially the same as with updates
as House Bill 504 from the previous uh
two-year session and that bill went
through review before this committee was
retained I went through an interim
interim study process and came out at
the end with a uh what's the right
wording that
a favorable report shall we say
ought to be considered for future
legislation
with a unanimous report from this
committee so that's that's background
last year also uh get rid of this one
piece of paper for you or put it in its
place uh at that during that process
the committee heard from uh William
Arden Bill ardinger he's a well-known
tax attorney and constitutional
lawyer
and uh
uh I had actually worked with him on the
uh
what was it called the school funding
commission he was the governor's
appointee and I was appointed by the
speaker along with others and uh he and
I both being lawyers work closely
together I admire the work he does and
within the purview of that commission
was this question of the Statewide
education property tax which this bill
addresses and he felt strongly that as
it stands now it's uh it violates the
Constitution and he felt it important to
come to a hearing on this bill and
testified to that effect submitting this
letter which I have distributed to you
at the time I spoke with him just
yesterday and he could not be here
regretted that because he feels he does
really feel strongly about this issue
and ask that I present this letter again
for him so that's background on that
the committee report from last year by
the way is at the tail end of this
two-page document my I've just reprinted
it down at the bottom so you can look at
that if you will
um
the the bill itself I'd say is is best
considered in in three pieces one is uh
the the part that uh
that is an essential reform of the
Statewide education property tax the
second piece reforms the low and
moderate
uh income homeowner income
property tax relief peace
that was originally put into the law as
part of the enactment of the Statewide
education property tax so there's a
reform to the taxpayer relief program
that's associated with Statewide
education property tax and that's the
second piece of this bill and the third
is a study committee to look at how
those tax relief Provisions might be
extended so that they would benefit
renters
um and also to look at other questions
that are noted in the bill itself so
three pieces so picking up on the first
one
um the Statewide education property tax
itself and the reform that's proposed
first thing to note is that there's no
change here in the rate
the rate currently
well now say if the rate for
fiscal year 24 the next fiscal year
reverts to the statutory rate that has
been in place for a long time which
requires that the commissioner of
Revenue set the rate Statewide rate
equalized at a level sufficient to raise
363 million dollars
and um and then there's a rounding
allowance so we can set the rate at uh I
think a quarter of Penny
um
yeah quarter Cent
and so the amount that's raised
tends to be just above 363 million
dollars
um and uh I I
have to say this for fiscal year 24
because this year it's 263 million
dollars and that's a temporary provision
that was put into the budget last uh two
years ago and uh and so for the year
we're currently in the tax bills were
based on the need to raise 263 million
instead of 363 million dollars and your
bills reflected that uh going back to
363 million dollars means about a dollar
44 equalized
across the state of course The Equalizer
rate is not what you see in your bill
because each town has slightly different
Fair variances from the equalized level
so no no change in the rate in this bill
that stays the same remittance to the
state however is changed and this bill
requires that all collections at the
immune the municipalities will continue
to collect the tax but the collected
money will be
remitted to the state
but after a hold back of three percent
of what is collected by the municipality
to cover costs of collection and costs
of promoting the taxpayer relief program
and that's new the three percent hold
back is new and the remission to the
state is New
um so first on on
why remit to the state uh that's what uh
Mr ardinger is concerned about the
current retention of money locally
under the current system
um
the money is retained locally and is
passed on to the locals to the school
district or School District serving the
town
um
and
um the problem the Constitutional
problem arises where the town collects
more
then it's entitlement to adequate
education money
and the excess above that level these
what we
refer to as excess swept
is also retained and kept and uh in most
places is then sort of spent as part of
the additional effort that's made on
education by that local school district
there are some places that have no
additional effort because they really
don't have any school kids they're small
places and uh and in those those
situations the money is kept and spent
on whatever I don't really know
um but they're they're small uh
collections
I gave you a handout a spreadsheet
um
and I'll just explain what's on there
you have to take it away and look more
closely I'm sure
but uh this has all the towns on the
left-hand side
and uh it also has the school membership
on it the total number of pupils a
trivia will are coming from each Town
um and then what you'll see on here is
uh a number of bars across the page
those are the towns that have excess
swept
that are collecting more
money through the Statewide education
property tax then their adequate
education
grant would come to
so Alton is the Delta show you on uh if
you'll take a look at Alton the first
town that you come to
alphabetically on the front page
you'll see right there in the middle
uh that they've collected I need my
glasses I can't even see it one one
million thirty nine thousand
795 have I got that right
um
and that that is the balance that's left
after what they collected was applied
against
the adequate education money that
they're entitled to so they've paid for
adequate education they still have
leftover 1 million thirty nine thousand
and that money is excess swept
um that excess swept is retained by
Alton I believe it's all applied to
other educational costs and um
and that's typical of most uh towns that
receive excess swept but there are
exceptions and again if I can see the
darn thing
um
if you go
yeah
a good example would be on the next page
I don't think there's any example on the
first page on the next page let's take
just go down to Clarksville
Clarksville
no I prefer going to go down to dixville
let's go down to Dick's film
um you see that Dixfield doesn't have
any school kids
they're still assessing Swift
and Dixfield is receiving 14
591 dollars
and it's keeping that
um and it then has
on its tax bill according to what uh the
dra puts out each year
um a negative
tax rate for its local education rate of
52 cents per thousand
so there's a lot of information on this
uh take a good look at it one other
column that I should mention is the
three percent uh that's now going to be
allowed If This Were to pass
um as a amount an amount retained at the
local level going back to Alton at the
top you'll see that the uh the three
percent retention is column K is a
hundred and thirteen thousand dollars so
that would be new Revenue to to Alton
that they didn't have before they would
of course be giving up the excess swept
so it doesn't really balance out
um the the reason for pushing uh for
remission of excess swept to the state
is really legal it is felt by
constitutional uh lawyers who look at
this not all I should say there's a
disagreement on this but that this in
effect the results in a disproportionate
tax this is a Statewide tax and you have
a town if a town is allowed to keep part
of it for reasons that are independent
of any Statewide spending program
then that becomes a disproportional tax
and uh and uh and certainly jeopardizes
its constitutionality
the the question is now before the
Superior Court in litigation that's
ongoing it's called the Rand V State of
New Hampshire case
um
so the second part of the bill is uh is
changing the
the taxpayer uh refund system making it
far more generous
it makes it more generous but and and
all of the refunds would be paid out of
swept collections it uh
it makes it far more generous by
um
extending the calculation of the tax
that can be subject to a refund to the
local education tax
revenues as well as the swept revenues
um so that for a particular taxpayer
they'd look at their tax Bill and they
have the swept amount there and also
this school tax amount and those
together would be the amount that would
be eligible for a consideration for a
refund I'm not going to go through the
detail but there there's sort of a
laddered uh a sliding scale that that
means that the low-income property
taxpayers get a get a hundred percent of
their tax bill if they're below
up up to up to a point it's kind of
complicated I don't want to take up too
much time here so I'm trying to do it
without going into that detail but there
is a sliding scale and you get more of
your very low income and if you're
sitting in a house that has uh some
value to it
and then it it go it goes down as you
your income goes up to a point where you
receive nothing you know no longer
eligible
um so that's the second part of it you
can look more closely at that I I think
it's a good good set of numbers that are
in that they're always there's always a
better way to do it so I'm completely
flexible on that part of the bill
um and then the third part is uh is the
study and uh you can look at the
language of that again I won't
bother you right now with going through
that it's easy easy to read but it
basically is trying to see if there
isn't a way that we could be more
helpful to tenants and of course their
landlords uh in uh
in a way that would be helpful to
to everybody and maybe to our affordable
housing problem
so I think I I'll leave it at that I
tried to rush through a pretty
complicated Bill and I'm sorry for that
but all the information is here
thank you that was a great high level
overview and obviously there's a lot to
read here so we will do that but would
you entertain questions right now
excellent representative Platt first one
I have and I'll take my turn for future
once is thank you for taking the
question if the state is required to
provide a hundred percent of an adequate
education
and you're taking three percent off
leaving 97 are we not only are we then
only paying 97 percent of an adequate
education
and thank you for the question the the
uh we're not subtracting at all from the
grant adequate education grant the
community will get its full Grant and
they'll be paid by the state from funds
that include swept funds and all also
the many other sources of funds that the
state
um turns to when it uh when it
determines what revenue is available to
pay for an adequate education so the
same formula would apply the same
calculation would be made they'd get the
same amount and I have to add that it's
a woefully insufficient amount
okay representative jinnegan
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
um the part that deals with um low and
moderate income tax
um not income tax law and monitors uh
income it's a mouthful
um
what actually now
um not throwing myself off
um
oh who is who would audit that I mean is
it each town to be responsible for
figuring out if the person qualifies or
is that
down to the state level that's a good
good question the administration of the
low and moderate income tax program is
is uh the responsibility of the
Department of Revenue Administration so
it's such centralized there and I'm not
sure what auditing has happened over the
years
folks we do have another pink card uh
for another individual plus we have dra
here to answer more technical questions
other questions for representative Ames
we'll be seeing you around so what
representative horse
thank you madam chair for taking my
question uh thank you uh so is this an
additional tax on the property tax if
people are paying now
it's an existing tax
um been around since uh
2001 or so at a higher level at six
dollars and sixty cents per thousand
then
it's now with this funny way of
determining the rate it's about a dollar
40 or so
and it shows up on a your bill anybody's
bill that has a pro has property it
shows up as one of the four
uh components of the property tax you've
got the county the municipal the
local education and then the swept the
Statewide education property tax
so it's it's it's not new
um yeah
follow-up question please
follow up
so I went through this with uh former
rep Doug Hall who you might know I know
him well okay very good and I have a lot
of respect for the man uh I just if I
understood the way this was originally
set up
certain towns that were
much richer than say where I'm at
Pittsfield Chichester area
I thought that money was supposed to be
collected and shared amongst the other
towns to help spread the uh the burden
you know to help out
the towns that don't have the numbers
such as
Pittsfield I think they're only
graduating 20 some students so student
numbers are going down but the the cost
of fund the schools are going up and I
thought this was supposed to help level
the playing field am I wrong yeah
and I I do know about Pittsfield that's
one of the towns that struggles most uh
because of uh low property values
overall
um
and um
I think there are two separate
parts to this
picture that we're trying to paint and
look at
um there is the sources of revenue swept
is just a source of Revenue it's nothing
more than that it goes into well right
now it doesn't go up to the state pot
it's kept locally and it's subtracted
out of the state's obligation so it's
applied against the state's obligation
locally but it's just a revenue Source
it's applied against that as I've
pointed out there's a problem because in
some places like Rye or
um we were just looking at what's the
name of the town
Alden
or moultonborough and they're collecting
much more vocally than is needed and
they're being allowed to keep it right
now and that I say should be in the in
the state pot for distribution out so
that's one thing the sources of revenue
and this bill is mostly about sources of
revenue uh the other part is the
adequate education program the the
program that's designed to spread money
out so that
um
places with greater need will get more I
think that's what you're talking about
and that is the adequate education
program is funded out of the education
trust fund into which this money would
pour as well as other sources of money
and that program right now
provides roughly on uh across the state
about five thousand dollars per pupil
um it varies because some places have
more uh needy kids than others and
there's some variation based on needy
kids
but that five thousand dollar Norm is is
way below what school districts are
spending or need to spend Pittsfield in
particular probably needs to spend more
because they've got kids that need a
little more attention and so anyway it's
a complicated story The the sufficiency
of adequacy but that's that's the other
problem I think that's when you started
your question with okay uh follow-up
question
one more okay thank you madam chair so I
understood that when I talked with
former rat Paul that uh this this tax
was going to be as I said spread around
now was it the Senate that put a kibosh
on that in 2011 from what I understand
and there's currently a move to get that
fixed yeah
um 2000 up until it's a little unclear
to me but up until definitely as of 2011
uh the statutory law was changed to
explicitly allow at least this is my
reading of it
um retention at the local level of all
swept proceeds
um and uh before that uh there certainly
was a period of time when the sweat
proceeds went to the state and went into
that pot and then were distributed out
Doug Hall is is helping in the lawsuit
that I mentioned that's pending the the
uh the Iran the New Hampshire lawsuit
and that lawsuit directly challenges
this swept excess swept retention system
and seeks to I think there's a summary
judgment motion that's now in play
that is being litigated with the state
of New Hampshire on the defensive side
opposing
the motion to declare the current swept
system unconstitutional and that's
before its Superior Court judge
thank you very much
so I guess like what begs the question
is this premature to do something like
this if this is in the courts actively
right now
you know my answer to that is uh yeah
maybe but uh there are many instances
where the legislature has felt that the
right thing to do was to go this way or
that way and there were tensions or
arguments over that which way was the
more constitutional so we could we could
make a judgment to go ahead there's
nothing to stop us and I at this stage I
favor that just because it's taken taken
so long to get these you'll you'll see
in my uh report and that's my report the
the committee's report
at the end of last year a reference to
this case that I've been mentioning Rand
yeah Rand V State of New Hampshire
um it was pending then uh back in
November and now here we are and uh now
there's another another motion and you
know it'll go on eventually it'll come
out but you're right
um the uh we could wait we could retain
this and wait
um I'd prefer to see it go ahead and get
these uh this this more uh
uh substantial amount of relief program
in place so I think there's a reason to
go ahead
representative Phyllis hi thank you
ma'am chair I have a question about the
second part about the low and moderate
income property tax relief program yeah
yeah
um
the do you have and and even a ballpark
estimate of what this might cost
thanks for the question there's a uh
there's a cap in in the Bill of 30
million dollars and if the cost of the
program exceeds 30 million dollars it
will be uh proportionally the the
refunds will be proportionally reduced
thank you
thank you representative leapley
um I had a question I understand the
three percent
um being retained
basically because there's a cost for the
municipalities to collect this tax I was
wondering why it makes sense for them to
collect the tax rather than having the
state do it
it's a part of what municipalities do
right now they they value put value on
property they uh they've got you know
they've got a system in place so I think
the the framers of this bill in the
first place back at the beginning of
2000 um
thought that they needed to assign the
task to the municipalities at that time
they didn't think to reimburse the
municipalities for their efforts but uh
I think that's appropriate and I should
add that the three percent the three
percent is uh parallel to what's allowed
right now in the rooms and meals tax for
uh restaurants hotels and so forth to
retain before sending in uh the proceeds
of collection
representative almond
thank you there's some stuff I'd like to
love to say but can't uh on it was 1999
but we I've got here and I gave to
everybody loan moderate income
homeowners property tax relief the
historic claims data
unfortunately it starts at 2010 it would
be more revealing if it started in 2000
or 2001 whenever we started the thing is
there a question but on what I wanted to
ask you was the claims have gone down
regularly ever since that program
started in 2010 there were 12 000 claims
granted for 2.3 million total and by
2021 there were 5 800 claim claims
granted for 1.4 million and
on
the part of the problem seems to be that
the forums are complicated uh the people
who would qualify for enough money to
make it worthwhile are uh not good at
complicated forms
and
um
do you have have you looked at at how to
make that
that on claims process
work better
so that this one would work
well
the page that you're looking at is from
the dra and uh as the administrators of
this this program they may be able to
speak to this I agree
um that it's complicated and difficult
that is
that is of concern I think that part of
it is that you don't get much under the
existing program
and so there's not much incentive to go
through the effort it will be different
under this uh this new program it'll be
more worthwhile so I think we'll see a
change there I think if I remember
remember correctly that the committee
that we're setting up is also going to
be looking at the issue and and the
three percent retention is explicitly uh
allowed to enable municipalities to
reach out to homeowners so there's that
element as well
thank you
thank you so much
okay we have a pink card from Zen I
don't know what this stands for NHS f f
p so please explain what that is come on
up
n a n a s f a p
yes we're the the only organization with
a long acronym
um my name is Zach Sheehan I am the
Project Director of the New Hampshire
school funding fairness project I have
copies of my written testimony coming
around that uh clearly identify that as
well
um I
we'll go through some pieces of my
written of my testimony but you all have
copies now and so I don't want to
reiterate everything you have and I did
want to actually expand upon a few of
the questions committee members
yeah it's coming making its way around
and I also wanted to expand upon a few
questions that committee members were
asking
um as well uh so first off thanks for
having me here this afternoon
um I appreciate being able to testify
um to start off we are in support of
House Bill 569 uh specifically because
it would make New Hampshire's tax system
significantly fairer in our view
um
there aren't enough
all right I can grab some more uh past
20 copies around but I can and the clerk
needs to retain two all right I will
I'll grab another one as well
um
so to start off uh just um some
background on why as an organization we
support this measure and also supported
House Bill 504 from last session
um specifically the property taxes uh
the largest tax collected in New
Hampshire generating over four billion
dollars to support state and local
public services just in 2022 it's
significantly more than any other form
of Taxation levited in the state which I
know this committee is intimately
familiar with
um yet the property tax continues to be
an unfair tax as it places far greater
responsibility on those low and moderate
income taxpayers than it does on more
affluent ones according to data from The
Institute on Taxation and economic
policy the 20 of New Hampshire
households are the lowest incomes
uh paid 6.2 percent of their incomes and
property taxes in 2018. uh compared with
the wealthiest one percent of households
in the state who only paid about 1.9
percent of their incomes
and despite the heavy Reliance on that
property tax
it our low and moderate income property
tax relief program does not provide very
much relief to our citizens
representative Alma you asked about
starting data earlier on I did cite in
2003 the program provided roughly 7.5
million dollars in property tax relief
to over 27 000 Granite Staters as
opposed to in 2021 only 1.4 million
dollars in relief and yet I don't think
property taxes have gone down uh in the
past 19 years it's actually quite the
opposite
um so in addition to uh significantly
increasing both the number of homeowners
and the value of the rebates they would
receive it would raise the income
threshold for the program which hasn't
been adjusted since uh Inception about
two decades ago
um it would also uh
tie
parameters would be adjusted for changes
in the Consumer Price Index which is
important just so that inflation doesn't
continue to erode the benefit of those
rebates which as a canoe is just talking
about might be a reason why some people
don't find it worth applying as the
amount goes down and the relative relief
that they would get from those rebates
I'd also advances taxpayer Equity uh in
another crucial way as it would end the
preferential treatment that some
property wealthy communities now enjoy
under the Statewide education property
tax
I would be happy to answer more
questions about that as well under the
New Hampshire Constitution it's the duty
of the state to provide an adequate
education to every child regardless of
where they may live
um going back to the Supreme Court
rulings from the 90s and the Claremont 2
to the extent that the property taxes
used in the future to fund the provision
of an adequate education the attacks
must be administered in a manner that is
equal in valuation and uniform and rate
across the state
and
currently it's swept as far from uniform
as representative Ames is just going
over some communities with higher
property value it recognized as
communities with excess swept are
allowed to retain that excess revenue
and levied against their other taxes to
reduce them resulting in some towns
actually have negative local education
property tax rates of other communities
like Pittsfield that was being mentioned
are far from negative property tax rates
additionally there's another lawsuit
that was also mentioned that has been
moving right along in that lawsuit
there's been a couple motions there's a
pending summary judgment motion uh that
I think the state's response is due back
on Monday
um asking the the state to the judge to
order the state to stop this process of
collecting swept in this way to date the
state has never defended the
constitutionality of swept they've
simply highlighted the logistical
challenges of changing that in the
middle of a tax year which is when this
was last being heard last fall
the point there being representative um
relatives representative sanborn's uh
question uh that I don't think it would
be premature to act on this given that
you know to date no one has kind of
pushed back on the constitutionality of
swept and there might be a ruling you
know as early as in the next couple
weeks and so kind of moving forward in
this process I think would would give
the committee the legislature a jump
start on any potential changes needed
I'll end um by
pointing out that
this bill also takes into consideration
two key findings from the commission to
study school funding that met throughout
the year 2020
they examined the New Hampshire's school
property tax system in length in part
because it's connected so deeply to how
we fund an adequate education in the
state
and the two recommendations they made
the first is that the state should
eliminate the excess swept Grant and
such excess funds should be applied
through the reform distribution formula
to improve student and taxpayer Equity
there should be no blanket rebates
abatements refunds or grants of swept
back to municipalities
another part went on to state that the
state should enhance taxpayer Equity
through property tax relief targeted to
homeowners and renters through a low and
moderate income property tax relief
program this program should include
updated limits to income home value net
worth and we satisfactorily funded
throughout the state we believe that
house bill 569 starts to address some of
those provisions and we absolutely urge
the members to vote ought to pass and
I'd be more than happy to answer any
questions the committee might have
[Music]
are you aware that they're already that
there was an update to the low and
moderate income property tax relief
program it was effective for this past
tax year and people got rebates that
were more than double what they had been
before
I was not aware of that
representative
know that when
the legislature was hit with a superior
court decision on back in 2000 and
year 2000 I think that declared that the
Statewide property tax was
unconstitutional that at least the
legislature if not the court took that
to imply that we also had
unconstitutional County taxes and
unconstitutional on school Cooperative
School District taxes that were at risk
I was not aware that that Court ruling
meant those things I did know that
courts and decisions in the past had
um said that the swept was
unconstitutional and then also multiple
Supreme Court rulings have said that how
we fund education which is the other
half of the equation has been
unconstitutional and has not been
changed to date
thank you but it does that gravitas to
that
questions on this side
okay thank you very much for your
testimony thank you for having me
okay we also have dra here again to help
us understand all the moving Parts here
a little bit better
Mr Keane Wong
Mr Wong before you get started
representative fellow just mentioned
something that made me think
um she said that property tax refunds
were double recently and I'm just
wondering did we do something
legislatively recently Madam chair the
reason I know that is because it was my
bill that did it yeah and and so what
was the bill number do you remember or I
don't remember the number but it it
passed
no I don't even remember it didn't pass
not in 22 it would have passed in 2021
yep because it was effective for
um May through June as the application
period last year and it was the first
time it had been updated in in 20 years
but the numbers you see when you look at
the
um
um representative Ames Bill are the new
numbers they used to be much lower than
that so we recently made some progress
in that region and and just to since
we're just talking on the subject I have
a bill that has already been heard in
Municipal and County to make people
aware of the program because one of the
reasons the the the return was so low
that over the past 20 years there are
fewer and fewer people fell below the
the income cap so some people dropped
out of the program and and then the
payouts were so low that it just didn't
make sense when you can only get some
people can only get 20 percent of that
so this past time around the maximum
that a person could get would be about
350 dollars
and before that it was down you know we
were heading toward like a hundred
dollars or under okay thank you for that
okay go ahead and let us know your
thoughts thank you
good afternoon my name is Kim Ming Wong
text policy Council from uh from the dra
the dra does not have a position on this
bill we did prepare a fiscal note and I
just handed out the physical quick guide
on this bill
um and I'm here to answer any questions
uh but just as a fair warning I
personally am not very familiar with
with the municipal uh side of the dra so
um I might be taking more questions down
in having to go back to the office to
get the answers for you
I have a quick question because I've
seen caps on programs like this uh with
the uh
what was that all right research and
development tax credit and when we put a
cap on it it created this strange
situation where you'd have to wait for a
while to see if you got the relief yes
what are your thoughts on that for this
bill right uh representative so that
that will be true because there's the
cap on a payout for this particular Bill
per fiscal year is kept at 30 million
dollars and the uh the applications that
come in use is coming in from May 1st
through I can't remember the exact date
where it stops so whenever the current
process is that when the dra receives
the application we will review it and
process it and pay out if it's approved
everything meets uh everything is in
order the payment will be made and uh
with this 30 million dollar cap that
payout would that the relief payment
would be uh hold up until we receive the
last
application for that particular year
otherwise we'll never know if we meet a
30 million dollar cap
representative Phyllis
um
Under The Proposal
the swept tax money would be sent from
the municipalities to dra
what is your interpretation of of that
mechanism because we know that not all
people pay their property tax bills on
time do you anticipate that the
municipalities will send you the whole
amount even though they haven't
collected it or
water and then you have delayed
collections yes that could be a
potential issue representative
because this will be a new system so uh
the dra this currently does not have a
mechanism in place to do this if this
bill were to pass then we will have to
set up the system to implement uh the
collections of these monies from the
municipalities and the way how it will
look probably as is you say that's
something that we probably will need to
to look into further as we start to
implement or start to design the system
is to how do we actually mechanically
collect this monies and what as you say
what happens when there are um the
payments I'm going to assume that the
municipalities will not
pay on behalf of
property owners
so if they are late they will be late on
that end and it'll be late coming in as
well
representative homie
thank you madam chair
did you realize that the towns have to
pay the counties whether
they've gotten all of their own tax
money in or not at the time when the
counties have to be paid
my apologies I do not know
talk with someone from the municipal
division yes some of this
representative Shamrock
I think representative spilsbury was
first
he's to your left man I realize you
don't look left too often but
go ahead Mr Sandberg we'll go for you
and then we'll come over here I have a
clerk here who's very diligently
blocking my view
thank you madam chair uh on your
analysis
on the back side you you
mentioned two errors
oh yes is this something that right can
be addressed with an amendment to the
the bill so um
from when we were looking at the uh the
bill or
um all the LSR uh the the issue that we
found uh potential I don't think it's on
a calculation error on our end but it
can be double checked but the uh the the
the two thousand dollar uh increment in
terms of uh the percentage of the payout
um it caps out to zero before the
maximum amount that's on the uh the bill
so
um that could be something to be looked
into again
for both the single as well as head of
household
representative spilsbury
thank you madam Sharon
so in regards to the low income credits
there's both an increase in the
thresholds
which represents uh
one source of reduced Revenue
to the state that the state has to make
up from other funds but there's also the
change that uh
makes this applicable to the entire real
estate tax bill and not merely the swept
portion as the dra taken those two
different factors separately into
account in terms of Revenue impact
um
so the the change in the thresholds on
the one hand and the change in
eligibility to be expanded to the entire
real estate bill
because of the the cap of the 30 million
dollars so that would be the maximum um
impact that that would be incurred
I think my question shows that I'm still
confused on exactly how that would work
so admissions
um but I haven't completely
satisfied in my own mind
where the impact of the credit lies in
the case of the swept I believe it's
clear that the state makes up
the difference for whatever credits have
been granted to individuals
but with regard to the broader real
estate tax that's not clear at all
any other questions right now
all right thank you very much for coming
are there any more folks who want to
testify on this bill
seeing none we will close a public
hearing on House Bill 569
okay I think that means we are done for
the day great job
we have a house session on Thursday
uh and then we will meet again next
Tuesday or I think we're going to be
doing Revenue Agency presentations again
does that sound right
foreign
yeah so we're going to start sprinkling
back in the agency presentations
uh and then of course we'll wait to see
what the governor has to say on
Valentine's Day
thank you very much I will see you soon
and uh Republicans will schedule a
caucus probably uh next Tuesday after
we're done with agency presentations
say that again
I'm sorry is there a republican caucus
at 9 00 a.m on Thursday yes usually both
sides will caucus uh before a session
day okay and usually an hour before
thank you right
thank you caucus the Democrats caucus as
well before session day yeah so always
plan on being here an hour before
sessions start time
to be safe okay